wanna let this continue on
[Music]
down
a life that you never thought you know
[Music]
foreign
I could let this happen
[Music]
we
foreign
oh yeah baby hey howdy everybody thank
you for joining us welcome to wvdt the
voicemail dump truck is live from
dreamhack uh I'm I'm growing from giant
bomb with me is let's start down there
with them Emma why don't you introduce
yourself and then we'll get right into
it hello yes I am Emma Fife I am a
senior video producer with a folks in
gaming over on the fandom side of things
though also lately I've been doing a
bunch of projects over at Gamespot as
well Dan I'm Dan I'm a giant bomb you
know what I do Bailey I'm Bailey I'm a
writer and producer for fandom just
doing all that all those word things we
are going to get into the voicemail dump
truck real soon but I want to just check
in with you all how is your dream hat
gone uh uh me and Dad had some fun
adventures at a restaurant where we had
a magician yes I heard about this did
you guys yeah have you guys had any
encounters with any magicians this
weekend you know I haven't encountered
anything it's been a pretty petitions
yeah exactly I would say that my weekend
uh if yours is a 10 out of 10 mine's
like a 0.5 out of ten uh just because of
the lack of magicians in it uh but I did
attend a a rather raucous pool Gathering
uh yesterday yeah at that hotel at the
hotel yes I was not prepared for that
it's I mean it's April it's in San Diego
I was not expecting to look out the
window and seen several shirtless very
muscular people yeah just one arm in the
air bounce around I just wanted to party
so the shirt wasn't come
very proud of my shirtless body yeah
absolutely it is
spring break I know for like LAUSD
schools I know colleges tend to have
their spring breaks a little bit earlier
but I don't know I didn't go to college
in California so maybe it all lines up
and it's just you know the the spring
break Vibes are alive and well um on
this holy Easter weekend
it is how I choose to celebrate our Lord
and savior absolutely uh it is um it did
have Vibes of like an MTV Spring Break
show yeah that was that I just wasn't
ready for that yeah I'm like people are
here to celebrate Esports our other Lord
and Savior but no they were out there
just partying with this they had nothing
to do with Esports I don't know if they
if I would have to talk to them I don't
think I was going to say I think if I
asked one of them what League of Legends
was I'd get some very blank stairs yeah
yeah
prepared for please what a goddamn
warlock to put my 20 bill out of a lemon
it was um
in San Diego incredible dinner and
there's a warlock that goes from table
to table ask for your money Nick Ivory
Nick Ivory this magic man oh my money
out of a damn lemon it was it was quite
unbelievable it was the craziest stuff
I've ever seen yes uh yeah he uh took
Dan signed it it says Dirty Dan on it
yeah and then he's doing all these other
smaller tricks with it and like he's
like pretending to mess up and then he
pulls out the lemon with his knife and
cuts it open right in front of us yeah
and pulls it out had me think of a card
and I thought of the seven of diamonds
and he was getting money from all of us
and everything and then at a certain
point he pulled out three twenties and
flipped him over and written in Sharpie
and Bola it was at seven of diamonds
I was curious as to why there was
writing on that bill I was I because you
were like putting it in Grub's general
direction and I'm like is Dan trying to
like
to remember yeah I was gonna throw these
programs
[Laughter]
because it was it was a really good time
that restaurant was great as well yes
here in San Diego incredible delicious
absolute great food I've never been more
jealous of a person it really sounds
like you had the Primo experience of the
weekend we were sold immediately we
walked in and just kept getting better
and better yes absolutely and it's uh
it's kind of been honestly all downhill
since then yes oh yeah yeah it's tragic
really exactly uh this is voicemail dump
truck what we do here is people call
into our voicemail dump line uh it is
707 exit flew again I remember the
number they didn't have to ask you wow I
wouldn't I don't remember anything 707
exit flu people call in they leave a
voicemail typically it's around 3 A.M
when they're drunk when they're feeling
it uh
all right we brought in our friends and
family to help us this week and what we
do we have a list of voicemails why
don't we just hop right into it yes love
to Emma okay why don't you pick the
first voicemail okay I would like yours
I would like to pick
certainty
all right
what's up dump trucks Tony in Twin
Cities uh just a quick question for you
today uh is there a video game character
that you can say with 100 certainty has
pooped their pants as an adult all right
thank you
it's not about not being able to hold it
in he does it deliberately as a power
move
ironically also and I I've said it but
I'll say it again Master Chief he poops
in the suit yeah but that's like how do
you get out of that suit fast enough
it's to even the suit eats his poop oh
that also it's some of his others
it has to be from the books though
because I feel like if it was in the
games it'd be like in in Metro you know
you gotta like clean the thing off you'd
have to press a button to like no
there's like a whole cut scene where he
talks to Cortana about it and she's like
the quality of your poops is not as good
as it usually is
suit it also is measuring his health how
regular he is like based on how liquidy
yeah yeah corn content
and get some other store
I think they terraformed the corn fields
on reach or something I don't know
anyone I mean like um I'm trying to
think of Grand Theft Auto characters
that might appeared oh yeah Trevor
Trevor yeah Trevor does it for fun
exactly I'm thinking most these
characters are doing it for fun Wario it
was an accident Warriors is chaos every
day like Wario is like my dad like his
toilet broke a couple years ago and he's
just too lazy to fix it right so he's
just [__] his pants exactly yeah my
first inclination maybe just because
like I have Resident Evil on the brain
is like re2 era Leon Kennedy when he's
just like little baby cop Leon and he's
like very ill-equipped for everything
that he's facing he's basically just
soiled pants 100 like yeah buy the gun
buy reform he's like sharding every once
in a while yeah
yeah a lot like hivo it's like he's just
trying to like yeah
um I I also think that uh Dr Mario when
he's in there just a little bit sharding
a little bit as well yeah how powerful
stuff in there when he's trying to get
rid of the the diseases or whatever yeah
yeah he's earned it yeah absolutely he's
earned it right he's got a doctorate yes
he didn't go to school for seven years
not to poop his fans exactly yes all
right uh let's get to the next voicemail
Dan the choice is yours let me know if
you need the list at any point everybody
I got it let's do uh well Stone Cold
right
hey L Kevin from Michigan just had chili
at seven in the morning cool
remake ET with so-called sdt you cowards
what just happened I don't can you play
it again yeah I heard something about it
just had chili at seven in the morning
remake ET with so-called sdt you cowards
Stone Cold s-a-t you cowards what does
that say I don't I don't really know I
don't know for Michigan one more time
in the morning seven in the morning
remake
Steve Austin I would imagine yeah yeah
all right well what era of Stone Cold
would you want to have like three if you
could rebuild stone cold at any point
what would you do late 1997 Stone Cold
Steve Austin come off Survivor series
with Brett or is that 96. yeah but now
he's not allowed to be a wrestler so
what job oh what job would Steve oh
Stone Cold Steve Austin a 3D platformer
he's collecting Steve wisers still yes
sure yeah
it's like Bowser's Fury okay but it's
like an open world Victoria Texas right
he has to go around he can only hijack
pickup trucks and monster trucks okay
and he's collecting Steve wire Steve
wiser is the power up yeah were they
officially called Steve wisers that's
what he called them so out of respect I
like to call them sure he has his own
line of beers now so I think it's the El
Segundo Brewing Company yeah Stone Cold
IPA of course but that doesn't roll off
the tongue no no Steve weissers yes yes
I would like to see be a my I feel like
I want a Stone Cold Steve Austin
in-depth uh restaurant simulator I want
to see Steve Austin run a restaurant in
like Arizona you know what I mean like
somewhere that's like he's retired yeah
he's retired it's a little perfect
pastry chef totally yeah like overcooked
it's like him the rock Triple H and The
Undertaker yeah and it's a chaotic
kitchen exactly yes okay yeah yeah I
think that's beautiful uh where what
would you do with stone cold if you had
complete control of his life uh I would
make him be an ice cream sandwich again
do you guys remember though
okay like the little novelty thing yeah
they did those WWE ice creams for a
while and he was if I'm remembering
correctly a really good ice cream
sandwich did he look really messed up or
was it yeah oh yeah I think it was
mostly just like on the wrapper and then
there was like a really weak ass print
of it on the front that I would have it
no other way it wasn't like Stone Cold
shaped it would be like yeah
I feel like this is the first time I've
thought of these ice creams in easily 25
years so it's all sort of coming back to
me at once but I definitely remember
them kicking ass yeah Stone Cold tastes
really good yeah so it's called Stone
you're thinking yeah oh yeah that's
right we could do a Cold Stone Cold
Creamery
there it is yeah we found it yeah
beautiful license game license IP yeah
okay all right uh Bailey why don't you
go go ahead and go next there's your
list That's so exciting yeah
um I would like to do
uh Lemmings all right Lemmings please
yo when the hell are they gonna make
another lemming
that's it right
yeah he's right yeah
great point I I've never actually played
Lemmings really really oh it's fun yeah
I mean I I understand the general idea
right what do you think the idea is I
think that you are in charge of a cult
of lemmings and they basically follow
you wherever you go and you try to
convert a lot of them it's a lot like
being here now or you know like and
you're going to talk to someone from
Scientology sure yeah that's right it's
like it's great you'll have like a
certain amount of like okay on this
level you have five blockers where you
can make any of these Lemmings who left
unattended they will just March off a
cliff yeah but it's like okay this guy's
gonna be a blocker so when he gets to
the edge he goes like this which means
the guys will bounce off okay yeah and
this guy these guys will have umbrellas
so they can go down these guys will
build stairs going up to the thing okay
so it's like a puzzle game but there's
like a timing element to it that's
really cool yeah it's awesome yeah
you're basically trying to get your
Lemmings not to jump off a cliff even
though as is the lore of lemmings in
general we know that their their main
purpose in life is just to follow one
another off of cliffs but this game
really challenges that and and uh uh
he's very generous to the intelligence
level of lemmings okay
here's my understanding is that it's
probably been
um uh they got to The Logical end of
what you could do with Lemmings and that
they probably aren't making it anymore
because it's like what other ideas can
you really do with it last one I
remember was PSP and it might have been
a remake of the first one yeah maybe now
it's about time to bring it back and
just if you want to remake it again add
some levels listen to your mouth oh yeah
yeah but we have to answer the question
when are they going to make another one
call the shot 20 24. okay uh I'm gonna
say
third quarter
2026.
uh never it's illegal now all right okay
I'm going 2028 let's see who can Price
is Right rules that you can't go over
all right everyone set your watch I'm
writing no I'm write it down right now
in five years when I'm right look look
at me in the eyes there will never be
another Lemmings don't ever ask me about
that again also the one coming in 2026
will be Lemmings VR actually if you want
another Lemmings uh Dave Lang on Twitter
yeah make another limit iron Galaxy iron
Galaxy yes Adam boys yes all right uh
all right I'm gonna pick one let's go
with don't mix them up
hmm
Gabriel Portland hey why do some people
say
poor if they're outside it is the ground
if you are outside is the explore if
you're inside sure always a hundred
percent of the time don't mix them up
for inside ground outside it is weird to
say you're picking a quarter up off the
floor if you're outside
[Music]
he's right yeah I I see so the rage here
is that you're you're picking something
up off the ground
floor
yeah something so yeah you pick
something up off the ground right you're
outside because the floor is
categorically inside I just think it's a
very narrow way of looking at the world
I think is the yeah ground not the floor
of the earth I feel like floor indicates
that like it was man-made yeah it's a
driveway though that's outside and
that's man-made yeah you say if you pick
up a quarter of a drive I think I would
say the driveway
the floor you're a sociopath yes 100
right yeah that that is absolutely
correct uh no I think yeah you might
need batteries
it's so sad that your microphone died on
the one that you picked it's like the
universe just doesn't want your opinion
on whether ground is floor and floor is
ground because I I see the argument of
if it is
man-made then I think floor is more
correct than ground
but also like what part of the surface
of this Earth that we're walking upon
wasn't touched by man
so true let's say have you ever been in
one of those like casinos like uh the
Paris in Vegas yeah where it's supposed
to be like it's outside right the
ceiling is the sky right and it's
supposed to be like a pavilion like yeah
is that the floor I don't know I think
maybe ground is anywhere you can get
worms if you're walking on it Barefoot
and if you can't get worms on it it's a
floor okay right right I'll take the the
grub note here and I'll pass to you if
you want to uh pick the next oh [__] I
don't have the list because he wants oh
yeah
the creation of Adam
um let's do
delicious fabulous
thank you Jesus
okay so picture this you're on the beach
enjoying a hot dog it's delicious yes
fabulous it's amazing
but you got a little sand on your hot
dog you just brush it off oh is it fine
uh how much sand is too much sand before
you gotta just put the hot dog down so
okay so what I really want to eat the
rest of those hot dogs oh yeah of course
you don't want to waste yeah so I think
you got to get a water situation
involved I know you're by the ocean uh
you don't do the salt well there's salt
in hot dogs so maybe it's okay but
either way you gotta get I would go to a
drinking fountain and uh you got to make
sure it's one with a good Arc so you
don't rub it up against the gross right
right and you just run it under the
water for a little bit get a paper towel
around it to get anywhere but then
you're washing off all the condiments
that are on your I don't know that's why
I don't use it all right in the event of
sand yes
think about a hot dog what makes a hot
dog good is it is smooth enough that you
can clean it yeah yeah like that is it's
got a casing on it yes I don't do any
crazy ketchup or mustard stuff so I'm
not looking right that's crazy ketchup
and mustard that's weird how it's just
so crazy
ketchup and mustard no one does that
basically like it's from space Dan it's
like from another planet just the only
things you can put on a hot dog cheese
and chili everything else is crazy yes
I've never had oh no no my wife had me
try mustard once it's the only thing
I've ever tried mushrooms on a hot dog
and it was weird I was very brave thank
you for acknowledging that
um but no plain hot dogs or just loaded
up cheese forever my hot dogs are
mustard only but I gotta say yeah there
is a high enough percentage of poop in
sand that I'm gonna need to like soap
and water that hot dog before I feel
like yeah but there's poop everywhere
like Yeah and I don't want to eat it but
you have home
you basically live in a butthole well if
she made a hot dog it's like it's a
really cute butthole
she made a hot dog though it doesn't
automatically have cat butthole on it
just yeah but is it like a hot tub also
basically just cow butthole I don't want
to hear about how it's made I assume
it's just pure nothing weird about hot
dogs I'm sure Chef Bob is is it good
don't tell me Chef Bob no I can't hear
yeah yeah yeah thank you definitely it's
like tofu it's just it's yeah
well you can get hot dogs that are tofu
which is soy really yeah they make soy
hot dogs yeah but those those are
horrendous they have a terrible texture
to them I I love tofu but like when they
try to make it into another like this is
gonna be like that other thing it
actually you bite it it's like you're oh
my God this is not that no oh and it's
not that maybe sand would improve a tofu
dog though maybe like you're missing
that like grit that texture that salt
yeah exactly I think actually if I was
having a tofu dog I would just I just
embraced the sand you know also like
babies eat so much sand and they mostly
turn out okay so unless it's like you
know there's that cookbook like salt
acid fat sand yeah yeah it must be onto
something yeah right exactly it's one of
the main flavors out there saying the
food pyramid yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
it was debunked but they still put sand
in there now sure yeah the current
guidelines yeah so it was the soup yeah
they don't recommend like massive
quantities of sand but given how options
you're not going to overdo it yeah all
right let's see
who uh who's uh Bailey just picked one
okay Emma let's go with you I'm gonna
say uh
we're hearing somewhere yeah we're
getting someone else in our uh I hear
someone else in my ear yeah I'm gonna
say Mario Kart oh yeah all right let's
do it
still hearing a mystery man hi it's
Nathan from Tumwater Washington
which character do you like to be in
Mario Kart and why oh yeah what was the
question
your Mario Kart Main and why
people were clapping I'm like yeah that
is a city
take the determine water Washington is a
regular uh here on the voicemail oh I
see
uh that one's my bad for not knowing the
lore of your show yeah you should feel
ashamed or embarrassed absolutely the
wiki it's like on fandom well Luigi is
the answer while Luigi actually in the
community for a long time was really the
top tier pick for like serious players
yes really you put them on the on the
caterpillar thing uh the wig oh really
you put them on wiggler and give them a
slide although in the latest update that
has changed okay they nerfed Waluigi
they basically nerfed they nerfed
Waluigi
come on like Waluigi always gets the
short end of the stick just let him have
this that I think it's literally like
they haven't like updated the balance of
Mario Kart for forever they're like yeah
there are too many Waluigi I do not like
this my name is Shakira biyamoto and I
don't like that so I would play oops all
while Luigi's yeah that'll be his solo I
mean that's what going online really was
it was waluigi's on wiggler do you
remember before Mario Sunshine and they
showed a trailer for Super Mario 128 and
the trailer was just 128 Mario's running
around give me that actual game
yeah Super Waluigi 128 that's the one
everyone loves Waluigi they need to
start embracing him he has legs for days
diamond eyes yeah drive like a wizard
he's wonderful he's clearly didn't sell
uh yeah well but he makes it work for
him he Embraces it would an encel bite a
rose
yes and I also think that um
waluigi's canonical medicine she's pro
tennis player oh yeah you know well
these are like legitimate babies too
yeah you know in that Series yeah and
ghosts yeah yeah I like it when Waluigi
really beats the baby in tennis yeah
yeah that's good stuff makes you feel
good I feel like he should be better in
Mario Kart because if his car fails for
some reason he can just Sprint to this
yeah he can just run I think he's got
the like T-1000 Terminator he does that
yeah yeah
toned I bet he just got a six-pack under
there I bet he does like Finn Balor yeah
I've seen some art on the internet when
he definitely does
it's like that um Undercover Boss sketch
with uh kylo Ren where they where uh you
know kylo Ren is being the Undercover
Boss and he goes like Waluigi would do
that and go around spreading the rumor
that he has an eight-pack oh yeah for
sure gotta be like drawn on with Sharpie
yeah oh totally clearly like very
important yeah like not anatomically
correct at all no that's just not where
abs are but he drew them there so but
that's where they are now yeah but
actually in Mario Kart I I am a daisy
Mane yeah really I don't know why I just
like committed to Daisy as soon as she
became an option because it was a
different girl character than Peach who
was typically the only option and like I
don't know Daisy's a little she's got a
little more like SASS and tomboyish to
her um so yeah that's Super Nintendo
World did he pick her uh Power I sure
did
and like um Mario Strikers where she
like kind of did like a little booty
shake when she scored at her Nintendo
uncomfortable was Pauline ever in one of
the sports games or is Pauline just
brought back like with Odyssey
might be unlockable in the latest
Strikers yeah let's get her back in the
cannon like Pauline's awesome no she's a
mayor give her something she's busy
though she's the man exactly that's true
yeah um all right Dan it is your turn
let's go ahead and bring you up all
right let's go with how's it going
hey this is Nathan from Tumwater
Washington yeah yes I get it now
how's it going
another like it's pretty nice it's a
little overcast weirdly cold I expected
California like I know San Francisco
gets cold but like I expected LA and San
Diego to be more like consistent 70s it
was like Chile yeah yeah why did I even
move to Los Angeles what's even the
point yeah
it's rained a lot this year in L.A and
you know I'm not paying La prices uh for
the rain so is the drought over like is
it official
at this point right it is the biggest
thing that these rains have done for us
is that it has significantly decreased
the Wildfire danger so summer Wildfire
season probably not happening and that's
good but the landslides through the roof
yeah not not so great it has fully
eroded the coast like a lot like the
train doesn't run normal it turns out
you can't start any fires if the state
falls into the ocean that's true yeah
it's so funny it's a trade-off sort of a
Centralia Pennsylvania situation
underneath us all the time man that's
the trillion thing I'll never really
understand it there's a fire that's been
burning for 30 years
that's a shoot this is a shoot yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't work this with you
uh in a place called Centralia
Pennsylvania there is a cave system that
like I think they were mines it was old
mines and uh I believe they decided to
like burn some trash down right like
burn something away yeah and that was
not a good idea because the fire's still
going it's been decades can't they just
squirt some water down there and
I mean I said that as a joke but yeah
Dan I think they probably would have
tried that they probably just put a hose
in the ground encourage them hey have
you guys tried water yeah yeah they know
what they really
go-to for fire it is yeah they need to
take all of those um Sandy hot dogs that
you drop oh yeah and the sand on the hot
dogs probably and I don't know hot dogs
might make it worse or better it's like
yeah it's like a grease fire yeah
you can't bother the hot dog yeah
exactly you don't put water on it
that'll make it bad but no no dogs but
hot dogs yeah yeah exactly hot dogs
truly the cure for anything how's it
going otherwise I mean yeah it's cloudy
here the weather is what it is but like
yeah I've enjoyed San Diego San Diego
San Diego yeah cool yeah I spent 12 days
in California now with the last like
four or five I've been in San Diego yeah
I think I'm very Pro San Diego right we
wait a lot we have a pretty poor opinion
of of SF I mean SF and L.A not really
fine with LA yeah I really enjoy enjoy
San Diego yeah San Francisco hell hole
garbage fire of a town
hell on Earth right terrible crowd
agrees yes Jan Jan hates San Francisco
uh welcome to V wvdt the voicemail dump
truck live I just got a producer's note
I gotta do station identification that's
right you're we got traffic on the tens
we simply cannot be fined by the FCC
again we got dumb questions from Dan on
the nines that's right I guess that's my
segment
yeah they've got the bear in the air
doing the the cop report later don't
worry everybody uh we're on top of it
all right I think next question actually
you already went so I'm gonna pick one
here
I have uh okay let's uh I want to hit
this one uh Scarlet Maiden okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah scrub this is your fault
I'm playing Scarlet maiden and I'm
enjoying it and it's all your fault
I think you guys should have a uh perv
corner for these types of games that are
actually playable
again your fault thank you now uh I'm
sorry Jeff I'm picking up some context
here despite knowing what's going not
knowing what Scarlet Maiden is sure Jeff
you recently uh we were sharing a
computer a game library
and uh the first thing you said to me
when you realized I had access to it was
like ignore all the porn games yeah
maybe is this what Scarlet Maiden is oh
yes okay oh very much okay cool so what
I've realized is they just straight up
have porn games on Steam now and it's
not like um yeah oh it's like there'll
be a extra sexy lady it's not
pandemonium too right right right oh now
we've like really like if we put
something the heroine is in a bikini
right yeah yeah there's lots of hentai
games but like they've actually gone a
step further and now they make full
games this is basically a dead cells but
it's a dead cells where you play as a
lady who is uh Buxom I think is how I'll
describe her in a boob situation yeah
boobs okay okay I'm wearing very little
clothing and then they animate all the
Jiggles and The Wiggles right right it
would I mean why what's the point if
you're not going to animate the Jiggles
and the wiggle exactly but it doesn't
stop there basically every sort of like
power up station is
um a sex act let's say oh well there'll
be like a fridge uh that has a wang and
you do that stuff to it that was what I
was gonna ask was like are you banging
humanoids oh just everything humanoids
uh sometimes actually sometimes like a
snake with a pretty face that's a lady
wow
sign off on this does Gabe know this is
on his platform I think game is I think
Gabe's the reason they're on the
platform I think he's like real freedom
of speech Dave's just sitting there
juggling his knives freedom of boners
I'm ready to go you don't want to know
no knives are on the Woody yeah I'm I'm
fully sorry to this caller I did not
mean to do this but there's a ton of
these games and it's there's something
very strange about a super sexualized
video game because I come from a world
where I grew up on Nintendo yeah and
that it's not even
thought about let alone possible you
can't even bleed on that so it's like
it's almost like this weird novelty like
this just looks like a real video game
but there is there's a butthole yeah
that's a butthole but there's a lot of
banging yeah what sexual game I've ever
played is probably balls 3D sure yes oh
yeah yeah and that was like innuendos
right for all the names there's a lot of
that but there were just like this is on
the Genesis so it was just like two
spheres where the boobs
no BMX triple X for you uh no no I had
self-respect the guy game uh oh that's
like illegal yeah right that is that's
right and I think BMX triple X is one of
the games you can't stream on Twitch oh
yeah totally yeah even though it's it's
rated M I think I think it's just like
this is way too egregious right yeah
Scarlet Maiden probably can't stream
that on Twitch yeah I would guess no
that that sounds like it's against
TOS but is it sec would you say it's
sexier than the Matthew Perry sex scene
in Fallout New Vegas
let's not set the bar so yeah I mean
what are the supposed one of those
sexual creatures to ever live Matthew
Perry he's you can just hear how into it
he is
he's just super invested in in that
voice acting it is weird though that
like you grow for these things and it's
like it just becomes like this novelty
where like on PornHub like the one of
the top Search terms is like Roblox
and like Minecraft that's mostly Jeff
Bachelor though yeah yes I mean he's 90
of those you search it up it's gonna go
up in the train absolutely yeah
it's like to try and find the uh ship
tags of the characters that I ship with
one another in video games sure because
if you find their ship tags on Twitter
like that is the best way to find Art
yeah yeah I'm gonna show my internet
ignorance here ship tax yeah so like
ships like nautical no no no like a
relationship okay okay yeah I believe
that the term like sort of originates
from the X-Files where people were like
shipping Mulder and Scully yes and so
yeah so it's the it's taking the back
half relationship that's a ship and now
they do like cute you know names like I
recently learned that the um ship name
for uh Leon and Louise and Resident Evil
4 is Serenity because it's Luis Sarah
and Leon Kennedy and I was delighted
when it's like it's JLo yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay I don't think Liberty
couple names
it's definitely better
thank you so much honestly that's all I
wanted to hear
all right also it's your turn if you
look at the next voicemail oh I guess it
is my turn um okay let's see
um
let's
do
uh
let's see best seven out of 10 games
sure
hey guys bill from Boston here
I wanted to ask if what is the best
description for a game you've ever heard
I once had a friend describe Dragon's
Dogma as the best seven out of 10 games
he's ever played and yeah I think I kind
of see it there are things that are
great about it and there are things that
need a lot of work
so calling it the best seven out of ten
seems really uh really apt for that I
love that what are some of the best
descriptions you've heard
that's 7 out of 10 games makes me think
of a thing that I talk about a lot with
movies these days and I think we've lost
the art of the uh Sunday afternoon on
TBS
which is like back in the day there were
a lot of movies that were just okay you
know they were just kind of a fun time
and it was great to watch them on on
public television on a Sunday afternoon
but now it feels like it needs to be
like outstanding or it's terrible right
there's no in between there's no there's
no room all those games have been
completely exciting yeah a reality yeah
the the term that gets me actually
personally most excited is a dad game or
a bad game yeah it's got like oh it's
like a blue collar like worker game and
I got a truck and the trucker gets stuck
in the mud snow Runner the snow Runner
yeah still Runner or a heart space
shipbreaker where it's like I'm just
working my shift yep I'm gonna go bridge
I'm just trying to get out of debt I'm
sending all my money home to my kids
yeah
oh yeah I love a dad simulator like
that's what I call uh The Witcher 3 uh
The Last of Us which agree is a zaddy
simulator
I mean some might say that so is The
Last of Us yes definitely more so you
know with the television series
we're really revisiting Joel's status in
general as is Addie sure absolutely uh
also uh my favorite description I've
heard of Fire Emblem uh which came from
my twitch Community is sexy anime dress
yeah yeah waifu chess yes yeah waifu
chest yeah oh yeah I refer to um Kenshin
impact as breath of the waifus that's
really good that's actually the best
answer for this question absolutely yeah
I always use a b game and I think a lot
of people think that I'm I'm speaking to
A Game's quality when I say a b game all
right God I'm saying like oh there's
Triple A you always hear about that and
then there's like Indy and more and more
over the years that's kind of been the
Divide yes and that's why it's like
something like evil West that came out
recently or back in the day like
condemned or the suffering or total
overdose or any Midway game any Midway
game that's the thing yeah I love Midway
like that stuff that wasn't the biggest
budget in the world it's not this high
production
but it's also not Celeste a little
anything or stardew Valley right it's
like you know it's less than sorry
Valley and I'm just thinking about how
much I like those games
I love big budget stuff and then I also
but I really miss the days of like
Midway like the wheel man and stuff like
that you know yeah stunt man give me a
stomach Game Boy Advance like uh get in
there like that that's the thing with um
I was always worried about the switch
it's like all right Nintendo's bringing
all their games onto one platform are
they going to stop making those smaller
games that they would have made for the
DS like kind of did Rusty's Real Deal
Baseball well
like Clubhouse games we got games that
would have been on DS right they're like
kind of willing to do a 40 50 game here
or there brain age that Big Brain
Academy right exactly although that
never came out here in North America no
no a Big Brain Academy okay the like
online one did Brain Age didn't come out
here right they did yeah Sudoku style
yeah yeah
um all right Dan I think is it your turn
to pick the questions all righty let's
see let's go with agent of blank
hey uh 3 A.M boys it's uh 5 p.m here uh
I got a question for you uh Dan loves
Waluigi who he describes as the agent
yeah we're pretty much on the DM
what character did the rest of you guys
love that you describe as an agent of
blank
so like agents of Love or
tears or something I don't know what
would be your Alter Ego love you bye
love you too thank you for the call
I would say you know Waluigi already
taken agent of chaos
uh staying in that same kind of family
of names I would say proper Luigi is an
agent of anxiety yeah yeah and that
really resonates with me patron saint of
anxiety
yeah if he can fight those ghosts so can
I yes absolutely yeah I I think um
tingle I've always been here
agent of weirdos have you ever dressed
up a single uh no but we can make that
yeah
that's a feature right there I don't
know what you're playing I don't know
what you're doing but I know you're
interested
yeah yeah let's do it it's just you but
you're like playing dad games
yeah Tico's got weird love yeah that's
like the most divorced Dad out there
just give him a trucker cap exactly uh
but yeah tingles tingles by guy I love
Tango out there gyrating in weird
corners of the world yeah yeah all right
I'm gonna talk to this throwing confetti
like Rip Taylor yeah yeah it makes me
excited about you Emma
um I'm gonna I think that I'm gonna say
uh that
krom from Fire Emblem Awakening uh who
was my number one fire emblem husbando
for a long time because uh I very much
the term morosexual applies meaning like
oh like sexually attracted to morons uh
so uh I'm gonna say he is an agent of
himos yes he is he absolutely is
all right you're listening to the wvdt
you happy Jan 72 degrees 72 degrees here
yeah
oh the bullhorn guys back he said he's
very happy about fire I've never been
able to see it because of these stage
lights but like there's just a guy with
a bull horn in the crowd that's a crazy
feeling and he's jump scaring you
yeah very encouraging
[Music]
okay tell all your friends uh let's do
this next voicemail let's go with gout
gang please gout gang
hey John from Nashville this isn't so
much for the show so much as I say if
y'all make gout gang merch I'm buying
that [__] uh so you know do without what
you will Scout gang for life thank you
okay all I know about gout is Benjamin
Franklin had it I think yeah it does
have something to do with like Cavs it
has to do yeah with like your your legs
right like lower extremities okay I
think it is uh like kind of like atrophy
of the musculature it happens if you
don't have enough iodine in your diet oh
it has iodine in it too much red wine
too many livers
oh the consumption assumption oh I love
an old-timey illness yeah we have like a
clear way to avoid it and people do
still get it and it's very sad but also
eat some salt yeah if I have like a
Centrum every day am I am I avoiding
gout is that all problem do I don't know
if I have a high iodine diet or not you
probably do it's mostly really easy like
98 high enough okay it is like
maximum iodized to avoid like as much
science has worked in our favor they've
said please eat all the salt you can so
that your legs don't get swelly and
painful yeah do a tequila shot it's fun
it sounds good Salt's good yeah oh well
yeah Salt's good let's go right off here
of course all right quantities I
actually when I was in high school I had
a friend who are okay so our English
teacher for American literature uh she
was on the verge of retirement uh she
thought it was okay to use some outdated
terms to refer to Native Americans sure
cool I'll I'll let you imagine what that
one was uh and and she swore it was
completely fine because she truly just
had absolutely no idea so this uh guy in
my class my friend James he this was
early internet days
early 2000s he prints out a page that
looks like it is a web page off of up
like MSN you know this is again early
internet days and it is a article about
how Benjamin Franklin uh was a marijuana
user which let's be honest he almost
certainly was oh yeah yeah that guy was
splits
but my English teacher was so obsessed
with Benjamin Franklin it's where she
knew everything about him so James made
this article and he goes to me he says
Emma Miss Salem will never believe me if
I present this to her but if you present
this then she might buy it right so I
did air credibility yes
ability I give her the article I was
like oh I was doing some research on the
internet last night because I was a nerd
and so that you know totally checked out
and I was like oh here's this this
article I found about Benjamin Franklin
and his marijuana usage and so then she
tries to play it off like she absolutely
knows this because he had gout so he was
probably using it to manage oh sure yeah
yeah a few periods later by the time we
got to AP US History our the the word
spread amongst all the teachers so Mr
Owen our history teacher was like yeah I
heard about what y'all did in English
class this morning don't worry I didn't
reveal you that's incredible so when
teachers are Bros yeah sure we are
definitely going to do gout gang merch I
could almost hear Jan's eyes like light
up backstage
it was like last week or whatever on the
show where like he did discovered like
yeah this moment where like oh red one
there he is jiren but red wine I could
make a gout way worse he got very upset
yeah uh we're all we're all very we're
going to get very seriously gout gang
it's gonna be a very respectful shirt
I'll just keep eating salt
never it's never hurt anybody Dan that's
what I think except slugs except for
most people with heart disease uh salt
is good has no mental mental benefits I
don't know where I was going I don't
think it has any calories I just have a
bowl of salt I will eat a salt it
doesn't have to be about about carrying
out I'll just do it yeah yeah
what do you think would happen if you
only ate salt
I think uh I would get shrively I think
like my skin would get like you know
real reasony yes I think it would suck
all this is my organs would be real
screwed up I think do you think you'd be
mummified
um when I die I think I'd mummify
quicker quicker okay I was gonna say if
you eat a bunch of salt isn't that
technically preserving your organs
because that was one of the earliest
ways for preserving right you're gonna
live longer I'm gonna start this is
gonna be like my Atkins diet the RICO
diet is just gonna be a bowl of salt in
the morning every day it's calorie free
there you go yeah no downsides all right
Bailey why don't you pick the next
voicemail I'm uh scared of and therefore
want to listen to temper tantrum let's
do it oh
hey John bomb this is Bill from Boston
got a video game question for you all
um so what's the angriest a game has
ever made you what what's the most
temper tantrum moment you've had at a
game whether you were a kid or even
recently yeah because I remember being
eight years old playing Super Mario Kart
on the Super Nintendo
and the computer in that game straight
up cheats
and I got so mad I didn't throw my
controller I didn't throw my system I
took the game out and I threw it into
the trash barrel and never thought again
never told my siblings what I did with
the game I just threw it away because I
never wanted to play that game again it
made me so angry it's pretty valid
what's the angry she's ever been I
I love you bye I definitely love you too
thank you for the call I've I very
rarely I don't really get angry like you
know people throwing controllers and
breaking controllers yeah that's never
really happened to me yeah me neither
Not To Break Cafe but you know I act uh
I act really angry you know I'll lose
the Mario party which I don't think has
ever happened on the internet but now
we're shooting here I I will I know it's
never happened on the internet no I'll
act very upset you know it's a show
we're putting on a show so you know it's
good if the bad guy loses and hates it
so really because at dinner the other
day you kept going like this no no no
again that's part of their cameras you
know it's for the show unrelated yeah
there were no cameras uh the one time I
remember just like by myself playing a
game and getting absolutely Furious was
I was playing Mortal Kombat 2 on the
Genesis and I just wanted to beat that
game with every character and every
difficulty unlock it yeah all that stuff
and I got near the top of one of the
ladders on like the hardest difficulty
and it was Molina oh the singular is
that stage where I had the spikes on the
ceiling oh yeah and I was just like I
just need to get past Molina and I was
Sub-Zero I was trying to cheese it just
and freeze uppercut slide over and over
and over again and it just she was
moving so fast I don't know if it was
just some AI cheating thing but I just
remember like hours trying to beat her
and at one point she's putting the
controller down and grabbing my pillow
as a kid and just like punching it
that's the only time I've ever like
struck something playing a game out of
anger was that yeah I I definitely have
I'm similar where it's like it hasn't
happened too many times and these days I
don't get too angry I just get kind of
sad yeah but I'm like Bubsy 3D I'm like
trying to beat that and it's like it is
miserable and then something terrible
happens it's like I could yeah I could
rage mostly I just feel defeated yeah
and we're like we're speed running punch
out now and like when we lose though
that game is so good that I think we
just came out of there we're upset with
ourselves oh yeah I should have done
better right yeah I I do I get pretty
angry pretty easily not with them not
with something like that yeah it's like
us that's not the game exactly it's just
totally on my execution I could have
done better yeah some RNG it was like
frustrating sometimes but yeah I respect
that I do but I I will throw it I like
how I fit I very I had an immediate
answer because something happened very
recently on a stream I was playing I've
been playing through the Nancy Drew
mystery games the PC games uh from Her
Interactive the classics uh and I was
playing The Phantom of Venice Nancy goes
to Italy uh to solve a mystery or
something actually I think she's just on
vacation and then it gets ruined by a
mystery but at one point you're like
walking into the Villa where you're
staying and you look up and a pot like a
flower pot
hits you on the head and kills you oh
and you have like a split second to find
the exact pixel to click on in this like
mid-2000s ass PC game to not die from
flower pot and I died like 15 times in a
row before I got that pixel and I just
sort of like stood up and walked away
from my computer and my screen was just
an empty chair with cute little gamer
lights for like a crisp five minutes I
really need to just take a lap around my
apartment my apartment's not very big so
it didn't take that long yeah like it
made it a breather I was so mad oh Nancy
Drew can't you just go on vacation and
be normal for once no definitely not I
am the first thing that's coming to mind
for me is when I was streaming Final
Fantasy VII remake I was so determined
to finish the game that day I was so
close to the end but right before you
get to the final boss you have to do
this [__] motorcycle bit and the
Motorcycle bit I just fully was not even
understanding the concept of how you win
that fight and so I just kept dying over
and over and over again and I was like
all right I gotta take a break I'm gonna
walk away and like put up my be right
back again similar like did a little lap
came back went full screen camera and
just started like chatting to my um to
my cat and I was like okay I'm feeling
better I got a glass of water I think I
get what I'm supposed to do now maybe
I'm gonna give it a go again so I go
back into the game did not put the
gameplay back on the screen
so there is now an emote of me like this
oh very good
on this this race
one of my friends who was watching
stream texting texted my roommate at the
time to be like can you go knock on
Amazon
she didn't put the game back on but she
didn't want to bother me so I was like
I'm like again doing this race and I I
lost again but it was during that time
that I figured out how to do it and so
then I was like oh I got how to do it
now and I look at my chat this is
everybody
wrong thing wrong scene
it's very spielbergian Paris
this is the monster the story isn't
what's happening in the game it's what's
happening it's what's happening if you
were directing correctly nothing was
happening in the story it was a
motorcycle do you guys have any like
moments of like Triumph in games where
you actually like stood up and like
bellowed in like Glory or anything like
that uh Tyson speed running yeah I was
gonna say probably the first time I got
a sub 10 on a Haiti Speed Run yeah
something about speed running yeah yeah
it doesn't Hades is very good too yeah I
think most recently I was playing Hades
I've been playing Hades again because I
mean I'm getting back into it Hades two
is coming out yes
excited and I was you know trying to
shake the rest off I used to be amazing
at it and now I'm like fine at it and my
major weapon that I'm good at is the bow
and arrow but I'm also really good at
the spear and I had yet to win the spear
with the spear and so I was playing
recently and it was really close and it
was like down to like my last hit point
the only hit point that really matters
and I killed my dad in the game and sure
the celebration the victory I caught a
fish right after it was the most
beautiful glorious moment I it felt like
the gods were truly smiling upon me and
saying way to kill your dad in the game
oh so good yeah that's one more thing
and uh the witness that I was like I had
it before there were any guides out
there and I was like trying to like
write some guide stuff for it never
really did that before but uh there's
this puzzle in a boat with these sounds
and it was so obtuse and I just spent so
long on it and I started like recording
the sounds and put it in the premiere so
I can like look at them and actually
figure like putting all the various
pieces of that puzzle together and then
softly didn't have it actually click in
place and work I got up and I yelled and
screamed it was like I think my
neighbors were like looking over at me
yeah
yeah it's uh that's such a fun moment
also recently playing Resident Evil 4
remake in chapter 11. there's a really
dope boss fight I'm not gonna
explain what makes it so satisfying if
you figure out the thing but it's very
satisfying is it uh speaking generally
yeah it involves like a yeah okay I did
it that way and felt really cool
if you you get money if you beat up I
know but it's so satisfying if I went
back I reloaded it
all right okay yep yep well I felt very
clever and I was poor for it but you
know what rich rich in my
accomplishments yeah
Bailey I think it's your turn I just did
this oh yeah I think it's me Emma okay I
know I pick really let me know if you
need to know which ones are left yeah
I think I need to know what's left
there's uses that that's what I was
going to say is uses that back let's do
it okay let's go hey uh uh how's it
going uh you you think that that the
Luigi
is that vacuum for anything else
my God what does he mean cleaning his
apartment yeah yeah maybe his car yeah
he's definitely keeping his home clean
oh yeah he's like a tidy boy does he put
his weiner in it oh my God I don't think
Luigi has one
no they I've seen blogs on the internet
where they try to that's not canon
that's not canon well it's from official
images
no he hasn't is there any evidence
this is my evidence those overalls tight
as hell man
has anyone there's never been any uh
like anyone having sex with Luigi or
having a kid or anything sexual does he
have desires is there any time in
Nintendo history they keep trying to
pair him up with David let's be real he
is not her type
[Laughter]
so she would step on him for sure yes oh
yeah she's she's got her eyes elsewhere
I think I'm I'm completely opposite I
think Luigi's got a huge hog where does
he put it the vacuum
it's uh he was raised by drag queens so
um
excellent Tucker right that's what he
uses the vacuum for too but he's
constantly he's constantly jumping on
Goombas and turtles and stuff and I feel
like that would wear and tear would
happen yeah a really really good Jox
trap to be fair maybe he did have one
and then he did use the vacuum and
sucked it off oh maybe yeah
like a belt yeah he's too close to the
Sun or it's like long and skinny now
that's why Luigi that's why yeah yeah
yeah
uh all right I think we've tapped that
one out I don't know I think we could do
a lot more on Luigi I'm afraid so I'm
talking about Louisiana worried about uh
Dan why don't you pick one of these last
three here yeah what do we got let's go
with uh uh one big hit
hey dumpers Colin from Bel Air Maryland
question for you in a game would you
rather do one big hit or a bunch of
small hits would you rather do 1000
damage in one year
or 100 damage 10 times
love you guys bye love you too thank you
for the call it feels
fuel fast character it's like
you know our games like Tekken where
it's Jack and the first one
exactly oh yeah you can do the wind up
yeah yeah and uh that feels really cool
but it doesn't how often is that
actually gonna work I know so I prefer
like you know like a mitrugi or a Taki
or something in Soul Calibur like yeah
yeah exactly yeah I think in a fighting
game I like a lot of fast quick hits I
think if I'm doing like a um a from soft
game I go for the big hits I try to get
one big hit that does a ton of damage
the big number feels good I mean are you
even playing a from soft game if you
don't have a sword that's like eight
times your own body mass yes and then it
does like like an atomic amount of
damage yes yeah
for me this is sort of the like Super
Smash Bros melee like Zelda V Chic
situation where like do I want to be the
Chic just like juggling someone in the
air a bunch of times or do I just want
to do one really powerful sidekick and
knock them right off the stage and
honestly the sidekick is just so much
more satisfying yeah like yeah the Smash
Brothers says come on I like doing the
jiggly Puffs like down b or whatever it
is or it's like if you time it right
they just instantly go flying off the
stage I think Smash Brothers has maybe
the all-timer as far as a big hit where
if you get the Home Run bad oh yeah
it's the best yes sir there's a thing I
really like to do with Zelda which is to
teleport on top of someone oh yes yeah
that's fun man that is really fun I am a
uh
uh but it doesn't surprise me Bailey
because you were talking about how in
Hades your best weapon is the bow and
the bow if you use the right build you
can basically like One-Shot Hades yeah
so that makes sense to me I on the other
hand my best weapon is the fists oh so I
like a lot of little hits
the fists give me carpal tunnel I just
don't know how to do them right without
hurting myself
yeah Dan how's the hands doing
I think it's getting better I'm on like
a month and a half break from the Tyson
speed running it's tragic but uh I think
I'm maybe a couple weeks away from being
able to get back in I'm doing the
stretches you got to tuck the thumb do
that above yeah yeah so have you guys
had any like we all played video games
all the time have you guys had any
similar issues with your hands because I
I've had issues like that but not as bad
as Dan's having right now yeah we're
going to entice it over and over and
over and over again yeah I was getting
like wrists yeah that's what I was one
of my viewers shout out to Sarah the G
sent me an anime boot girl mouse pad so
yeah it fixed it yeah it fixes
everything yeah I was like I get these
now I tried the vertical Mouse before
where it's like oh the weird ball oh
yeah it's one that's actually it works
just like a regular Mouse but it's like
you're doing a handshake oh okay and it
always felt very formal with my computer
like hello sir yeah like some video
games sir sure yeah yeah how about you
Emma how your hands holding uh mostly
wrist problems also I I also have a um
padded mouse pad it's not anime boobs
unfortunately but it's to buy yeah no I
think it has like flowers on it because
again I was a emergency purchase of oh
no everyone knows that flowers are the
boobs of the plants are the boobs of the
Plant World so it's basically the same
thing they add the flower with the boobs
remember in Conker's bed first that's
right
but that was on the that was on the
pistol and or the stamen that was on the
sure all right flower doctor
it was not on the the pedals right no it
was in the boob range if if that is the
face up here this is the yeah yeah it's
weird how um it burst into my brain that
image of that sexy flower is I think I
need to talk to somebody I think there's
no reason that should still be up there
like I should have moved on by now I
just think it's so cool that we're so
committed to our love of video games
that we're sacrificing the one human
body we have on Earth to play them yeah
it's true love that for all of us it
gets better as we get older once we get
older it'll get better I'm sure yeah
all right um let's go with uh Mario Kart
please
we've done it we've wrapped up all the
questions then oh thank you for
listening the voicemail dump truck
before we get out of here how do you
guys feel how do you guys feel like we
really tackled did we help people today
yeah yeah I think so I mean you know if
if nothing else
um we've really given back to society uh
when it comes to deep burning questions
about
um the anatomy of a certain beloved
Nintendo characters their place in the
world how they self-identify as an agent
of yeah yeah it's a beautiful thing and
we've talked way too much about Luigi's
weiner yeah so yeah we got yeah
objectively too much about it
I'm expecting a Stern talking to from Dr
dreamhacks
it's not positive
well thank you everybody for listening
uh once again I'm Jeff from Giant Bomb
that's Dan from Giant Bomb Emma um
Bailey joining us for fandom thanks for
listening until next time have a good
one take care of yourself and goodbye
bye everyone
[Music]
like the right one now
talk about
foreign
[Music]
the last time I saw
foreign
[Music]
for me
too
foreign
[Music]
so distance
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
stars to
Dustin What a Wonderful World
for us
waiting for you
in the Stars tonight
What a Wonderful World
for another
life waiting for you
us
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
gesture gently and touch upon the sky
he's gonna change
[Applause]
[Music]
I believe
everything everything
three
days
[Music]
[Applause]
show everyone
[Music]
why
nobody
could come
[Music]
a life that you never thought
foreign
[Music]
being today when
our
[Music]
house
thank you
[Music]
last night
make me
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
like the right one
[Music]
tomorrow
Jesus
[Music]
the last time I saw
foreign
[Music]
too
much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
equator
[Music]
foreign
replace
cycle with your answers
we will officially get this started
hello everyone and welcome to are you
smarter than a games journalist
it is a trivia competition with prizes
today we have bold contestants and if
you're sitting in the audience and
thinking man I'd like to try to be a
contestant you could be one so just let
that ruminate in your brains uh because
we are looking for more contestants in
our competition today let me first
introduce our resident games journalist
who all of our competitors will be
playing against today from Giant Bomb we
have got Dan record and Jeff Gray
journalists you're welcome for us being
here you're welcome
wow the response there you could tell
the love and adoration for games turtles
in school in college oh yeah oh those
heady days late nights yeah oh boy
pouring over those books yeah oh that
was yeah well well studied well
researched well educated yes and that's
that's what makes us better that's right
he's trying to figure out which camera
to show his sign I know I'm it's a bit
I'm trying to but it says what does it
take games turn are better people wow
he's a journalist he's not an
Entertainer then what hard to say yeah
better at what everything okay yes yeah
reading books
being folks oh okay yeah fantastic well
those are our games journalists I'm
going to turn things over to my co-host
Bailey right now who is on the couch
with our first competitor
hi everybody hello I'm Bailey I'm at
fandom with Emma and I'm also here on
the couch with our first competitor what
is your name first competitor my name is
Bob hi Bob nice to meet you are you
intimidated by our games journalists
just the facial hair actually I yeah
yeah look at that I'm envious his soup
catcher is really something else it's
great for microphones I found it
great not at all yeah I don't see any
fear in those eyes Dan Grubb he'd be
worried if I were you I I've never been
worried in my entire life I'm not going
to start now what do we have like 40
years between us yeah honestly yes
that's actually might be a real number
yeah
we're good yeah yes here it is well that
might work out very well for you because
uh most of these trivia questions in the
game today came directly from my brain
so just to give you a little bit of a uh
some information about myself so you can
get in the mindset for this uh I will I
am an elder Millennial I was born in the
middle 80s I also was the child of
people who were programmers in the late
70s so that's kind of just given you a
little gist of what's going on in my
head so that you can better prepare for
the competition uh head I don't think I
don't think your bright should count as
a source it's not official I would never
cite it in whatever articles
main sources all right
I didn't just assume my brain was
correct
[Laughter]
so how is this going to work
we are going to have multiple rounds
there will be five questions per round
everyone will answer questions
individually on their own whiteboards
and the final scores will be tallied
after question five if you are the
competitor and you have a higher score
than whichever of our games journalists
games journalists and Dan Reichert
you're playing again
what's the implication there if you have
a higher score than whoever you are
playing against then you will win a
prize
a prize coming from our partners over at
fanatical that we'll have to get your
info for so that we can send it to you
on Tuesday because they're in the UK and
they take Easter very seriously very
serious they are not going to talk about
this yeah they are not going to speak
they don't have jrpgs there so they
haven't killed God yet yeah exactly yeah
that's the problem really is God still
exists there so
all right anyway
are on the same white board right we're
all good for that yeah because you are
not going to be playing together you're
going to take turns playing okay perfect
okay it's not fair to have two brains
versus one damn okay yeah all right so
am I going up against him at all or is
this just scrubbing him you can nominate
which one of the two of you is going to
go first
let's see if it pays off all right any
questions again this is mostly um for
Grumman Reichert since you're currently
the only contestants with microphones
sure yes yes we have the power yes but
no questions no questions we are ready
to go well then I think we're ready to
move on to round number one round one
question one
with Wario in need of a doubles partner
what Mario title marked the first
appearance of Waluigi
first appearance of Waluigi I know this
one fear furiously writing their answers
Bob has very tiny handwriting he doesn't
want you to actually see his answer
I peeked over his shoulder
he's rewriting it now he got
self-conscious
it looked like he had the right
everybody has answers on their board
ready to go all right Dan what do you
got Mario Tennis the first one on
Nintendo 6. that is correct and Bob how
about you Mario Tennis Mario Tennis yes
that is correct well done Bob thank you
yeah
there's no other explanation he learned
that on our podcast yeah we are in our
journalism
a very serious journalism in the papers
the whole thing is really just full of
bibliography
yes yes it's like a medical report
you've gone deep into the microfiche yes
yeah
all right second question during which
convention did Nintendo announce their
intent to work with Phillips on a new
line of Hardware effectively ending
their partnership with Sony in 1991.
during what convention did the top 10
anime betrayal of Sony by Nintendo take
place
all right Dan has his answer Dan's
locked in but Bob is still working on it
Bob is working on it
Bob is
Bob I will give you a hint um there's
not so many gaming conventions that have
been going on for quite so long you've
got like a one in three shot if you
guessed yeah it's dream hack 1990. 1990.
I will tell you that what people thought
of as possibly the largest gaming
convention in the U.S um R.I.P uh was
kind of built out of a reaction to
game creators feeling a little
overlooked at this show not necessarily
supported
have we got our answer
all right it looks like all right we are
locked in Bob let's start with you what
do you got
Gamescom Gamescom that is a good guess
uh Dan Riker what do you got
I thought it was E3 but then you were
saying stuff that made me think it was
PDC
oh that is incorrect okay tell us what
it is
yeah yes the refrigerator thing that's
right refrigerator yeah now this
question was in there very specifically
for Bailey yeah and Bailey why don't you
explain why this is so near and dear um
to your entire existence well my my
dad's in the games industry and always
has been and he unfortunately did miss
that CES that year the only one he ever
missed because I was being actively born
when Nintendo was stabbing Sony in the
back on stage had he been there things
might have been different that's true
yeah Nintendo PlayStation yeah I could
have stopped Michael Myers could have
backstabbed
Nintendo while they were backstabbing
Sony but it was really cool because Sony
was so upset that that happened that
they made the PlayStation out of spite
this is true this is a true story it is
absolutely correct kicking off the
console Wars and changing history yeah
meanwhile Nintendo was like we have that
great partnership with us CD
it worked out really well forever all
right next question what was the very
first game to be awarded Game of the
Year at the game awards in 2014.
so that is the game awards as they exist
now the first title to win game of the
year
yup the first year of the Jeffs
man I was there yeah I don't remember
this one's a very this is very
specifically a games journalismy
question yeah
and yet they look so confused so accused
uh confidence it's a game that has uh
romance options it's a fantasy setting
that's that was gonna be my guess okay
all right pens are furiously flying
they are coming up with their answers
Bob keeps writing question mark isn't
really uh he's really doing some nice uh
adjusting with his fingers making sure
that the lettering is Perfect
Photography everybody locked in yes we
are all right uh Dan Riker what you got
Dragon Age Inquisition Dragon Age
Inquisition and what do you have Bob
breath of the wild breath of the wild is
two late Dragon Age Inquisition is
correct Dragon Age Inquisition all right
all right next question
Castlevania 3 protagonist Ralph C
Belmont is better known to players
outside of Japan by what first name
this is one of those confusing
situations where I think they just
changed his name because Ralph doesn't
really sound like a cool hero guy I've
known a lot of cool Ralphs yeah name one
okay
I was working Dan happy work over here I
really thought that perhaps they had
intended Ralph to be pronounced the old
English way which is rafe like a refine
yeah right like Ray fines exactly but if
you look at the um like Kana breakdown
of it it's so it's Ralph all right yeah
it's just Ralph It's Not Raven uh
everybody locked in yes all right Bob I
go to you first love what we got Simon
Simon all right and Dan Reichert Trevor
Trevor is correct there we go Simon's a
good name though good and Simon is a
great name and I clicked through fast so
we're moving on to our final question of
this round in the Metal Gear series Dr
Hal Emrick is better known by what alias
this is unfair this is unfair there was
a Waluigi question and a metal gear
question thank you thank you I tailored
it to you unknowingly honestly Bob wrote
his answers so fast and with so much
confidence not a question mark to be
seen heck yeah we love that and
everybody locked in on this one all
right uh record let's go to you first
that is an answer and Bob onacon
[Music]
it is confusing because he does say
oticon in the OG Metal Gear anyway
so but it is a reference to oticon like
the convention
otaku so this is Japanese animes yeah
yeah exactly
he introduces
pants and says he likes anime yeah
that's how I introduce myself yeah
honestly semi-surprised he didn't come
up in the conversation earlier about a
character who's 100 poops their pants oh
yeah he definitely has so yes this is
the voicemail.com
all right stand by Master Chief as my
answer so we're gonna check on those
scores here uh it is four four Reichert
to end two for Bob so that means that
Reichert you walk away Victorious
Bob thank you so much for playing with
us today
uh well done Bob good job Bob good job
thank you Bob for being our uh our first
victim here today you played very well
very well check out his restaurant thank
you so choose grass skirt yeah grass
skirt it's a it's a Tiki restaurant
that's right
a warlock pulled reichert's dollar out
of a lemon that's right but but listen
Emma there's some magic happening on
this stage right now there is and we are
about to bring out our next contestant
to the stage
all right
and this time they will be challenging
one Mr Jeff Grubb all right
that's right I'm ready to do it yeah I'm
I'm ready I'm ready for you to dive into
this I mean it was named are you smarter
than a games journalist and you know you
have one you do I identify as a game's
journalist yes on my tax papers yes all
right on your tax paper that's what you
list as your profession yeah is that in
the drop down menus on like Turbo Tax I
I write a special letter to Joe Biden
and Joe Biden I'm a Gangster and let's
deal with it all right Bailey who do you
have joining you on the couch now
introduce yourself hey everybody
okay yeah John Allen the voice of
Thornton and Brawley and Pokemon Masters
crying and Sylvanas and smite good to be
here all right
excellent well we don't have a
whiteboard for myself I'll just write
one okay fantastic great so we're moving
on to round number two in our are you
smarter than a games journalist trivia
competition here
question one
all right
established in 1889 as Nintendo karuta
Nintendo was originally in the business
of making what
Nintendo has been in the gaming industry
for a very very long time far predating
the Advent of video games
grub seems like he is locked in I am all
right and we have an answer here as well
okay we will go to the journalist couch
first
and contestant
I said arcade games arcade games in 1889
oh
you put a nickel in a lady dance
yeah
they really wanted to get it on the
ground floor
Bailey board because I already knew
these Bailey board the answer is indeed
hanafuna playing cards
thank you yes all right moving on to our
next I'm fired all right doing great
what 1996 Capcom title famously featured
a fog effects filled live action opening
cut scene with a handful of actors being
chased by dogs through the woods
I recently re-watched this opening and
there's so much fog effect yeah
the amount of fog is truly Wild
it makes me think that they were just
like in a sound stage with a couple of
branches and sort of hide the fact that
they weren't like really in a forest
they just kind of had them run around
yeah and great acting though A plus plus
acting truly set the tone for this
particular title we will go to the
contestant couch first what do we have
for an answer
um I just kind of shot in the dark here
resident Mega Man resident Mega Man
haven't personally heard uh or played
that one uh it's probably the right
answer then I went with Resident Evil
yeah Resident Evil uh is in fact the
correct answer uh yeah the resident Mega
Man seems like some sort of crossover
between a couple of big Capcom titles
not sure it exists but um I appreciate
uh the dedication to showing you know
what properties Capcom publishes and I
drew a mean dog
[Music]
all right next question
all right often incorrectly assumed to
be the name of its driver what is the
name of the iconic ice cream truck
featured in The Twisted Metal series
people think it's the name of the driver
but it's actually the name of the
vehicle
we have bonus points if we know the name
of the driver
uh also Trevor you get you you get uh
like clout points I'll allow you to tell
me what the name of the driver is that
beats me yeah okay good good good uh all
right everybody locked in excellent all
right uh we go to the journalist couch
first I went with Sweet Tooth Sweet
Tooth and to the contestant couch I also
went with sweet tooth and sweet tooth is
correct that is the name of the vehicle
Dan what's the name of the driver the
needles came it is needles cane and his
brother was the Yellow Jacket driver
yeah right yes okay yes all right yeah
that was I actually was amongst the
people who thought that sweet tooth was
the driver and then again when I was
confirming the facts in my brain is when
I discovered that most people
incorrectly assume that sweet tooth is a
driver but it's actually just the
vehicle fact checking as a games
journalist that gets me very excited yes
I'm uh look I've I've read a lot of
earnings reports
all right next question what non-sonic
landmark online multiplayer title
released in December 2000 in Japan did
Yuji naka's Sonic Team develop for the
Sega Dreamcast worth noting that this
game was great this game was great
it's the first time I had an online
boyfriend
not the last time not the last time
incidentally my online boyfriend's
Avatar's character was the name of my
real life boyfriend now
it's fate it's fate all right we are
going to the contestant couch first on
this one unless you're still locking in
an answer do not have an answer yet on
the contestant we do not have an answer
yet well anything okay follow your heart
follow your heart there were only like
two dick games made for the Dreamcast
really narrow it down if you just go for
yeah maybe three
and to the journalists couch fantasy
store online
[Music]
[Laughter]
two wow
embarrassing now I'm fired from that
game the Sega police I'm gonna get you
right now yeah the Sega police are
currently Landing their helicopter on
the walkway in between the bay front and
the Hyatt they're actually just
arresting Yuji Naka again
all right moving on
I'm having a great time you're doing
great man what 1997 isometric action
role-playing PC title published by
Blizzard Entertainment featured Warrior
Sorcerer And Rogue as the three options
for player character classes
a PC staple the only PC game I ever
really played outside of Age of
Mythology because I liked mythology
that was the entire thought process
behind it all right answers locked in
all right journalist couch I I went with
Diablo Diablo and contestant couch World
of Warcraft
the answer is Diablo
before coming out soon oh yes check out
Diablo 4. meet your maker when Diablo
Launches on June 6th I may have done a
project for blizzard with Diablo I'll
stop doing it
on our scores you know what uh grub I
gotta say you ran away with this one you
proved your journalist metal uh thank
you so much to our wonderful contestant
for playing parting words
I I'm so sorry
you did great I hope you don't get fired
from yeah yeah we'll we'll fight Sega
off for you if you if Sega comes after
you you tell him to take it up with me
all right how about another big round of
applause
I gotta say Emma the journalists are
doing pretty good they are doing pretty
well uh the thing is is
if you're familiar with are You Smarter
Than A Fifth Grader the questions are
questions fifth graders should know so I
went for the I think these are questions
a games journalists should know
apparently you guessed it correctly and
apparently I'm doing great so how about
you're killing us a big round of
applause
all right let's bring questions our next
contestant out to the stage who will be
challenging one Mr Dan Reichert my
understanding is he's gonna cheat
I believe he's cheating the same hell is
this
are you a metal gear what is this are
you a metal gear
all right what is your name contestant
uh hello everyone uh yeah y'all can hear
me hi so yeah I'm actually like doing
this like IRL backpack stream that I
just set up he's got chat with them I
didn't expect to go up against the
goddamn Predator
cyborg in our bits yeah yeah uh my name
is Michael otherwise known as smirky I'm
a content creator I've been coming to a
few dream hacks with the stream Studio
back there which you should definitely
check out all those oh you're the people
coming to destroy all the games
journalist job yeah
this is personal yeah all right I was
sitting in the crowd and I'm like I
actually know a couple of these answers
I'm I'm rather young but I I think I
have a good shot
are you gonna have chat help you a
little bit uh yeah feel free yeah cause
you're going against Dan yeah we're
gonna we're gonna see Chad's actually
been getting some of these answers all
right
we have the facts
you got you got the facts in your brains
and he's got the facts and chat this
also may come down to how quickly you're
chat can Google stuff if there's one
thing I've learned uh streaming on
Twitch it's that Chad is never wrong
about anything ever wrong about anything
and they are all god tier Gamers who've
never died once yep
all right moving on to round number
three okay
the placeholder Sprite for a game
originally called twinkle popo
eventually became the titular character
of what long-running Nintendo series
twinkle popo a placeholders right now
better known as a beloved Nintendo
character the contestant is actively
Whispering into his shoulder
problem it works but it could be
something different I don't know can I
whisper it grub
[Laughter]
since he's using chat you can use grub
we may need another another marker for
the contestant R seems to be doing
pretty important do you have a marker
Bailey Or Nah oh yours was taken away
can we get a replacement Sharpie Jan or
somebody backstage I think it's pretty
legible what you've done a sharper
that's actually a permanent marker
replacement dry erase we're working on
it but we do have our he was able to
write the answer enough though okay that
have been
a silver Sprite yeah I listen what I
have learned about trivia is usually
your first guess is right so go with
your gut and follow your heart oh I've
learned the opposite of that oh okay I
don't know what advice to give the
audience now okay cool great well
hopefully
Michael's audience has uh steered him in
the right direction I guess we'll see
we're gonna go to Reichert
first Zelda Zelda okay interesting
interesting Michael what did you
oh my okay oh we've got a stack of
papers pull out a whiteboard markers all
right so they give us a Sharpie and
paper so I'll use that now okay cool I
can at least project my answer of Kirby
Kirby that's that's correct
I had that but then Brett told me it was
Elvis
no yes grub LED you astray really did
yeah I was script I hate Kirby don't
want to see any Kirby answers up here oh
I know it's because I use the word
beloved
can't be curvy everyone hates it
obviously my favorite Chris Rock and hey
you beat them all right for the first
question heading on to our next question
here okay what was the first video game
familiar to a global audience to receive
an on-screen adaptation in 1986.
it was an animated film
that's the hint I will give you and the
other hint is the year 1986 familiar to
a global audience
there was actually another video game
adaptation animated released on the
exact same day in theaters in Japan
but it's some Japan exclusive title that
I have frankly never heard of
and this one is very very very famous
there was one right now before that but
I don't know that would be another clue
very very famous
furiously writing answers
my marker got replaced with the worst
marker
all right Michael Consulting his Brain
Trust his chat
writing down that answer all right it
looks like we've got an answer locked in
on the contestant side all right
absolutely has to be because it is
written and Sharpie okay that's true
there's no changing your mind Michael
what you got
I'm pretty sure it's not right but I'll
go with a shot in the dark and say the
original super Super Mario Brothers Dan
Reichert what's up Mario Mario that is
correct it was Super Mario Brothers
there's an animated one yeah right yeah
yes it was uh I believe it was Super
Mario Brothers and the daring rescue of
Princess Peach right uh there is a scene
in it where Luigi does shrooms like when
he eats mushrooms he gets high like
certain mushrooms will do to you oh yeah
Luigi's parties oh yeah Luigi definitely
parties and Luigi is greedy also in the
movie there's a little blue dog who
turns out to secretly be a prince and
Princess Peach's true fiance much to
Mario sadness
man this new movie sounds like it sucks
compared to this yeah
I mean this this is a masterpiece yeah
it sounds like a great film I cannot
wait to watch it all right
next question which character in The
Last of Us is portrayed by the same
actress in both the 2013 game and the
2023 HBO series
looking for the name of the character
the name of the character
try that
do you have any other guests
lots of whispering going on over here
we've got Michael talking to chat
relaying what he needs
what information he needs
just need a first name for the character
also technically the characters in The
Last of Us do have last names they just
don't really say them very well no it
doesn't come up that often there's only
like 20 people left in the world yeah
exactly I didn't get rid of last names
I mean it might get confusing on the off
chance that like one of the other
survivors is somebody you're directly
related to by Blood so like the chances
of incest I guess increase but I mean
what are the chances of even finding
another human being I don't know they
got bricks all over the place so yeah
anything's possible all right they're
just loose bricks answers locked in okay
we are going to go to you first record
Ellie's mom Ellie's mom uh and let's go
to Michael
uh I have Marlene Marlene all right here
we go
now Michael did you know that or did
your chat come through on that
uh someone in chat came through all
right
you're losing the chat meanwhile I got
grub over here giving me bad information
that is the power that seems right
also I believe Ellie's mom's name is
Anna I think so who could say who could
say I mean there's no way we could
possibly know that no well you know
in that episode in the TV show where so
we have a video game journalist I have
not seen the show I don't trust
Hollywood without an Entertainment
Weekly journalist all right okay fair
fair all right moving on all right
lavender towns Mausoleum like Pokemon
Tower is a hot spot for catching which
type of Pokemon
which type of Pokemon will you find in
the Pokemon Tower in Lavender Town in
the Kanto region
all right answer got locked in so fast
so fast there was no hesitation I assume
right now he's just like Whispering
Victory lap things yeah yeah he's just
he's just giving them words of
encouragement knowing like yeah I think
I'm gonna win this he said he's in a
strong position too with this so
all right everybody locked in yes all
right Michael let's see it what have we
got first okay I have a ghost ghost and
Reichert I also have ghosts ghosts yes
that is correct Ghost Pokemon in the
mausoleum like Pokemon Tower in Lavender
Town
all right saving you souvenirs final
question of this round okay
what game pre-packaged with the PS5 is a
celebration of the history of the Sony
PlayStation console
oh
it's a very good pre-pack game yes one
of the best yeah at a top 100 uh speed
run time in it oh you do I I think most
of his scores so I'm slightly better
than him this game
we had a month-long feud in this game
and my my score's on top yeah no way to
prove that yep all right we've got our
answer okay uh let's see an answer from
you first Reichert Astros playroom
Astros playroom and on the couch Michael
I know that's the right answer I wrote
Ratchet and Clank
uh Astros playroom is of course the
answer uh let's tally some scores shall
we Dan I believe you got three oh wow
which means that's pretty good oh there
are a couple of winners that sounds
right yeah it is Michael on the couch
with four because you only missed
a thousand people what the hell
congratulations twitch chat
back in my day we called that cheating
uh you were you were Consulting with
somebody you haven't all his answers
were wrong I didn't leave you out to
drive
all right Ellie's Mom thank you so much
for joining us uh see Jan before you go
so we can get your info so we can send
you a gift from our partners at
fanatical uh but as I say I won't have
codes from them until Tuesday so we'll
contact you then and we'll make sure
that you are appropriately rewarded for
your Victory today how about another big
round of applause for Michael thank you
all so much thanks man good job Michael
and booty or chat
you're all terrible people
good job Ben thank you
okay all right
time to bring out our next contestant
hello
[Music]
new contestant and what is your name my
name is Harry go by super flop with two
P's on Twitch oh wow well nice to meet
you Gary Superfly you don't have a chat
pardon me all right chat this time are
you about to smash a watermelon
Gallagher joke that's for the kids
that's for the kids yeah here's your
whiteboard here is your marker it
actually works
all right
so so you said that your name is Gary is
your real name Gary Harry oh I was
thinking like Gary like Ash's rival in
Pokemon yeah I heard that too I was like
all right all right well Harry Superfly
we're gonna move on to round number four
of our game here
and we have this
what arcade giant became Sony's first
third party developer and released a
console version of their popular Ridge
Racer as a PlayStation launch title
Big Time arcade makers of arcade games
in Japan
decided to join Sony
in the fight against Nintendo
follow him Mark the trail immediately
decided to stop working
immediately decided to stop working oh
no but the answers were written down and
I can see it you can see it all right
well Bailey if you can see it then I'll
Trust whatever your eyes are seeing I
know what you wrote all right we're
gonna go to Grub first on this one I
went with Namco Namco and how about over
on the couch the Midway Midway uh that
is an extremely good guess but Namco is
the correct answer Bridge racer is a
very good series Ridge Racer is a very
good series and they also released
Tekken as a response to Virtua Fighter
and it was better on the Sega Saturn yes
it was no battle arena Tosh in Denver
all right no battle arena then uh but
what is really I mean what other well
actually it was it was remarkable at the
time in ballerina toshend in three that
you could play as a tiny child with a
sword eight times the size of her body
now that's just standard practice but
back in Revolutionary revolutionary and
beating up children Revolution yeah
having just a little murder six-year-old
okay next question in the early 90s what
seven up mascot starred in virgin games
well-received platformer for the Super
NES and Sega Genesis
a shockingly good promo game shockingly
good yes
seven up mascot
got any guesses Harry who I feel like we
really need to bring back you know I
think he's kind of Gone by the way he's
so cool yeah yeah he was a cool dude he
had sunglasses
there's no noid I like the yo noid the
Noid yeah the Noid had a game too yes
yeah we did have a game avoid the Noid I
do avoid him
all right
writing down an answer taking a a big
swing in the dark
or not in the dark yes it's partly that
I think you nailed it not dark at all
all right
we're going to go to Harry first I'm
incredibly wrong with Pepsi man Pepsi
man
[Laughter]
yes he wrote that before it yeah yeah
all right listen I love Pepsi man it is
cool spot
wow
dang crap is brutal I didn't know
let's get away with anything
wildly mean all right moving on to our
next question
Which special bonus character for
multiplayer mode in Goldeneye 007 for
the N64 was famously too short to be hit
by the normal auto aim gunfire giving
players an unfair advantage
we had a really quick really confident
answer okay player couch over here the
makers of GoldenEye uh I am not sure if
they ever actually saw the James Bond
movies
sure because this character was very
much a normal height
very much a normal height uh in the film
he originates from maybe it was just
racism they're like that's that's a
little well they got him mixed up I
think uh with knick-knack from man with
a golden gun who was small yes so racist
yeah I hope you always look taller in
the movies than they are in real life
Emma Fair yeah Tom Cruise is four feet
tall yeah that's accurate actually he
has to stand on eight apple boxes to be
the height of his uh co-stars all right
let's go to the couch with Jeff Grubb on
it first Jeff what you got odd job odd
job and I also did odd jobs
[Music]
[Applause]
what a little jerk
truly when we played at our neighbors uh
nobody was allowed to play as odd job
yes correct
those were just normal house rules those
are just normal house rules that was
Jaws allowed because he was tall that
was actually like against disadvantaged
yeah yeah that was like a power movie
want to yeah I was so bad that I would
usually just play as jaws and be like
well I got bigger surface area so what
do you want me to do exactly
I would just hide in a room with Pro I
would just like put a bunch of proximity
mines in a room and hide yeah the
strategy yeah find a place where I could
snipe people yeah that was that was my
golden eye style of play all right
moving on to our next question
what famously reclusive mangaka designed
the characters for Chrono Trigger and
the Dragon Quest series
Amos Lee
doesn't like to do any sort of publicity
for his series
despite being arguably
not even arguably definitely one of the
most successful Magica in existence
all right answers locked in okay perfect
we will go to the couch with our
computer Harry Akira Toriyama and Jeff
Grubb Toriyama Toriyama Akira Toriyama
is of course the correct answer
Dragon Ball man that's the Dragon Ball
man
I'm not an anime journalist that's right
okay but like toriyama's contributions
to the gaming world have been pretty
significant there's a lot of dragon
quests oh yeah that is popular yeah yes
yes I've heard
all right well fortunately I know you're
not an RPG guy but you're not playing
right now because we got another RPG
question which Fire Emblem title
released for the Nintendo 3DS in 2013 in
North America dramatically outsold any
previous entries outside of Japan and
assured the continuation of the series
Fire Emblem title we've got our answer
locked in yes how they were locked in
over with our friend Harry Grubb just
finishing up his answer there all right
grub we go to you first Awakening
Awakening and I also got Awakening Fire
Emblem Awakening is of course the
correct answer I like the waifus in that
game I really like how you wrote it with
the G on the second line
yeah I got what you were going for very
very artistic all right time to check in
crush myself as a games journalist
scores
grub
I think that was another perfect round I
think so too yeah I was helping him a
lot yeah he was yeah with the anime with
the anime right yeah you're an anime yes
that's why you don't identify as a James
as a games journalist it's an anime
yeah despite the fact that you were
yelling at me about how you're not uh a
television ew he doesn't remember that
so he didn't know okay well that's fine
awakening's good Awakening is my
favorite Fire Emblem that's a good game
Awakening is awesome yeah uh look a game
really well thought Harry thank you so
much for joining us congratulations
am I talking to a twitch chat no okay
I'm not talking to a twitch chat all
right excellent
and we have one final contestant joining
us on the stage
who will it be we shall see yeah I uh I
miss the pair up system of Awakening
they they got rid of that that was fun
yeah yeah that was so I always kind of
want him to like maybe go back to that
but they always I know something
different it's fine yeah I actually
ended up really liking uh or engage yeah
I I enjoy engage as well I I thought
that the engage system was pretty fun
yeah the thing about the pair up system
in Awakening is like
you could have a real super Army if you
played your cards right like pairing up
an army army children soldiers an army
of super soldier children yes that is
correct oh all right my dreams oh geez
here we go
yeah random audience member we've got
here he's just a really big foreign
roots for the games journalist I've seen
this band professionally wrestle yes I
have thank you I've been me I hope these
are fighting game related questions
otherwise I'm screwed
actually the only answer I didn't know
was CES I totally forgot about CEs they
have a lot of refrigerators there now
I believe at one point there was some
talk of uh Razer creating a mask that
had like changing LED lights
yeah they're like oh yeah it's it's uh
what is the the oh it's good for
filtering out coven yeah that was a lie
they were just like we want you to spend
a lot of money some LEDs on your face
look like a real jackass
it says the guy with a speaker hat well
no this is cool
these cool dude stuff I can listen to my
podcast
all right why don't you introduce
yourself to the people in the audience
who might not know you hey guys I'm Alex
trebayley I run all the fighting games
in the arcade area you've seen all
weekend also internet personality former
pro wrestler
uh the face of twitch I am the global
email debated yeah
yes that's all you get except every time
I get an answer right thank you
all right well moving on to our final
round here is our first question the
Bailey couch I'm just realizing that
yeah yeah it's all bay leaves
all right
on the GameCube marks the first Nintendo
published playable appearance of what
titular heroine introduced in 1986
it's Ellie's mom yeah
we have got an answer locked in on the
contestants doesn't surprise me we will
go to the journalist couch first that
would be Princess Zelda Princess Zelda
and our contestant guy different answer
over here what did you write I put Samus
oh basically not playable characters
yeah as discussed lightly earlier Zelda
playable in the CDI games yes but those
are considered based on the Legend of
Zelda sure it was that one word that
threw me off
all right
moving on oh no what artist famous for
his wispy lines and vibrant use of color
served as a character designer I lost
the pen for oh he he was so mad he wrote
Samus down that he ate the pen oh he ate
the pen uh-oh pen down we are oh he's
got it everybody
[Music]
crisis averted
all right we did it we did it and now
you've had a lot of time to stare at the
question on the screen which is what
artist famous for his wispy lines and
vibrant news of color served as the
character designer for final fantasies
one through six
also famously the artist behind Vampire
Hunter D
uh which was very formative to my
childhood when I watched it on Prototype
Cartoon Network when I was about
eight years old you got the cool paper
little young for vampires yeah totally
cool all right are we locked in on the
couch okay uh what do we have for our
contestant
I've played every single Final Fantasy I
don't know this one so I'm gonna pass to
Dan
uh it's not it's actually a different
artist you said he was famous he is he
a few years ago
Romano became like one of the most like
valued artists in the world with with
sales of prints valuing something around
like 40 billion and he would do the
covers for like egm and they would pay
him tens of thousands of dollars for one
cover yeah this is a rich man y'all and
also he thought that the character
sprites of his very detailed watercolor
paintings were extremely cute oh
all right moving on that's the one final
fantasy question that's the one final
fantasy question well done
in supergiants Hades
which legendary Keepsake allows you to
summon Thanatos which I spelled wrong to
Aid you in battle I know this this is my
favorite Keepsake to use oh
I'm a baddie gal myself
um
the name of the legendary
companion Keepsake given to you by
Thanatos so you can summon him to Aid
you in battle
all right
everybody locked in yeah great not quite
not quite okay I'll give you some time
so mad because I put 160 hours into
Haiti and I've already forgotten
everything about that game
yes you're really looking forward to
Hades too then just okay in your brain
picture when you're about to start a run
sakes and you got your little guys down
here
which one do you pick if you want your
dumb death boyfriend I will even I will
even give you a point if you can tell me
what animal it is
I don't know
all right okay
I don't even know whose turn it is to go
for the journalists I believe all right
journalist side record let's see what
you got the heart the heart uh okay and
that's a note
that's not that little circular animal
thing I don't know the answer but yeah
I'm so sad because I played too much of
that game it's
my game of the year yeah
little mouse
I said I would count it if they could
come up with the animal but nobody did
audience do you know Mort that is
correct
way to go audience
no no no don't give them the microphone
I need that
the audience is taking over at this
point all right
next question
three years after the launch of the
successful Kings field on the Sony
PlayStation from software released the
first title in what long-running
Flagship Series in 1997 and I will give
you a hint it does not have souls in the
title hmm
laughs
okay
we are going we've got our answers the
contestant couch we got you Bailey I
think it's king's quest king's quest
I guess it's not we go to you Reichert
armored Core armored Core is the correct
answer
yeah that was kind of frumpsop's thing
before they got soulsy
Six coming out this year Yep they're
still making them yep yep here to put
Dan over yeah make me look strong
brother yeah when you commit to a
franchise that's what you get it's just
sequel after sequel
sequels much beloved in video games we
get tired of them in films yeah turns
out
all right
next question
what staple in-game maneuver in the
Sonic the Hedgehog series traditionally
achieved by holding down and a face
button is notably absent from the
original 1991 release of Sonic the
Hedgehog on the Sega Genesis
someone's just yelling the audience is
yelling answers okay Dan's locked in
lock it in
our we are writing frantically the
marker is trying its best to stop us but
we will not be stopped okay all right
the marker the marker is trying to
thwart us doing a self-portrait
beautiful all right I'm ready we got
this okay great so we go to Dan first
spin dash spin dash and over to the
contestant couch as a fighting game
player I have three answers it is known
as neutral spin
standard spin or spin dash
um learning to speedrun Sonic one kind
of fell down a hill and went cool I'll
just spin dash up it nope yeah nope
can't do that you cannot do that I
promise on that they did add it back
into the remake of the game they did
gorgeous but that was why I specified
the original Sega Genesis release
because it has been added in later
Edition so despite his answer of Dragon
Ball guy
Stan Reichert is still the champion of
this final round of are You Smarter Than
a Game
[Music]
where they can find all the fighting
game action for the dream hack yes yeah
grab the mic
tell people where they can find the
fighting games oh yeah guys so we got
Guilty Gear stride finals happening
right now followed by Smash ultimate top
8 which should start at three o'clock
and the brawl Hall is championship
series over there we're at first place
today is going to win 35 000 oh yeah
Cade will close at six o'clock if I see
you at 601 I'm gonna ask you to leave
thank you what
is he
I've worked a lot of conventions I run
my own Series this is one of the first
arcades in history that had a proper
partnership and branding So Am Pm came
in was a huge push to have us get more
machines than we've ever had before so
really cool shout out to AM PM and just
really excited it's only going to get
bigger from there so I'm excited gamma's
over there doing the dance games looking
real cool yeah I challenge Dan to DDR
later yeah
[Applause]
joining us here on the main stage at
dreamhack be sure to join Dan and
friends over at the arcade for a dance
battle later this afternoon uh come back
here in just a little while we are going
to be having a Mad Mario Maker uh
competition we have an evil mastermind
who has created levels in Mario Maker
for everyone you see sitting on the
couch to try running I gave him a spin
last night
they're they're a little tricky they're
a little tricky yeah I saw your face and
heard the noises you were making I went
oh God this is going so hard but for you
know Pro God tear games journalist
Gamers I'm just gonna spin dash through
it I'm gonna be fine spin dash through
it I highly highly recommend that thank
you so much everybody for joining us
we'll be back in just a little while
enjoy the rest of your Sunday here at
dreamhack
I can see
foreign
[Music]
until we can run
foreign
[Music]
together
so this time
[Music]
something you think
the Stars tonight What a Wonderful World
for another life
waiting for you
in the
Stars tonight
what a wonderful
[Music]
waiting for
him
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all flies
out turn down just don't build
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
itself again
life every day
[Music]
celebration
when you watch me
[Music]
Awakening
love but not your own
a life that you never thought you'd know
[Music]
foreign
thinking we
need to make it home
[Music]
Daddy
foreign
[Music]
the last time I saw
foreign
[Music]
remember
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
sorry
this song
[Music]
foreign
go with your
s
[Music]
foreign
including where we both began
[Music]
including
towards
[Music]
all right hello hello hello
people of dream hack people of the
internet welcome back to the live stream
for those of you who have been hanging
out diligently waiting for this next
part of our event to start it is time
for some Mario Maker Madness first let's
introduce the evil mastermind behind all
of these levels it's game spot's very
own day
[Music]
I can hear you yeah
so have fun yeah I will say that I was
testing out one of these levels last
night uh at the hotel bar and I did tell
Dave that I hated him so I have seen
these I have seen these levels our
contestants have not seen them let's
start with you Dan Reichert tell me
about your your Mario prowess
true Mario uh I haven't quite done speed
running stuff might go into that but
played all of them love them the
platformer specifically uh and spent a
lot of time making Mario Maker levels
myself so uh I'm very curious to see
what he's cooked up here all right so it
looks like we may have a ringer on our
hands here Jeff Grubb yeah I I've gotten
to a battle with a friend of mine we
went back and forth he was actually from
I actually made friends with him because
he made Mario Maker levels during the
review period for the game uh in Norway
we went back and forth he kept making
levels specifically for me and it was
really really great experience it's one
of the what makes Mario Maker one of my
favorite games of all time awesome and
last but not least Bailey uh I have very
very limited experience with Mario Maker
Mario I've seen Mario I have played
Mario games
are brothers I know they're Brothers
okay good I know you're a hotel Mario
speedrunner
Mario
a big fan of Platformers though so I
feel like as soon as I get a sense for
things I'll I'll be all right all right
well I am going to uh let Dave get you
all set up to get this party started um
Riker simply by proximity of where you
are let's have you go first but you know
we have to make this Fair uh we don't
want Bailey and Grub to get a chance to
watch Dan's play through uh and thereby
get ideas about how they might
successfully navigate this level so I
wore these cargo pants today just so I
could store these earplugs um for them
so we also have an added level of
protection so please help yourself to a
couple of earplugs there you go I don't
know how this is gonna fit in around the
in-ear I've already well you know it's
just gonna be fine it's gonna be fine uh
and we're going to be yeah and Bailey
you can just hold that up in front of
your face because we don't want you to
crush your eyelashes
yeah my beautiful luscious eyelash scrub
come on man
I see how it is all right
so
let's go ahead so the first stage is the
Enigma of amigara fault okay and uh one
thing you should know there are no
invisible blocks we have a four minute
time limit so puzzle boxer I guess I'll
find out won't I you'll find out okay
but there are no invisible blocks you
have to worry about okay I have four
minutes you said four minutes okay
am I good to go you're good to go all
right
grub currently tweeting blindfolded is
he peeking
no peeking
Luigi's crotch all right
what's going on in there
this is real cool there okay great
you're doing very good yeah you're
killing it
very good Dave I'm not a fan of what
just happened
all right
pretty good pretty good you're doing
great you're doing great yeah you have
to respond in ways that don't tip my
hand to uh the other competitors here
wait so what other
so there are no invisible blocks oh yeah
so all right try something else here
okay
sounds like you're doing good okay
you got this and it's a thinker yeah
you really need to get this yeah no
hidden blocks sorry this one is named
after a Genji Ito comic right like I
should be so scared
those
what kind of sorcery did you do and
putting this together
twin blocks I don't know that's why it's
the Enigma the Enigma it's an enigma
sounds like it's going really good over
there yeah it's going great Emma did you
beat this at the bar I did and just
remember this is the first level yo good
has he won yet no yeah I'm on the third
level now
what the hell did you do here
why is this like this it's just think
about all the environment items
in a Mario I am I'm looking at
everything yeah is this all for show is
this
if you wanted to Traverse through
something perhaps
I mean I just don't I don't feel like I
should give hints that might be unfair
I'm sorry I can't help it I don't know
should we yeah I think we should give
hints you're thinking along the right
lines
I don't know what his thought process is
maybe he doesn't have one
there's another direction that you're
not exploring yeah I look here
okay you don't have to worry about that
area don't worry about that he thought
about here and how are we doing on time
don't have to worry about that area
what about this area
maybe maybe there's something going on
here yeah what could be happening wait
hang on sir
there's no invisible blocks I guess
these can't be anything yeah wait is
there something going on back there
[__]
oh
okay all right
all right all right
just in the nick of time okay all right
okay 53 seconds left okay okay 53
seconds remaining and Reichert you have
completed the first level so excellent
so feel free to harass Bailey as much as
you like okay I'm allowed to watch them
right okay all right I'll leave you in
the right direction
because I still have my in-ear in and
I'm not gonna adjust it all right all
right but I don't all I know is it's
named after a Genji YouTube comic and
I'm afraid all right
let's see so all right it's a to jump
right yeah
and if you are holding why you can do
like a run jump
yeah there we go
grab literally twiddling his thumbs like
an evil villain right now now that
people know all right seriously cool
cool all right sweet yeah great
um
what
my hint to you Bailey is it's an enigma
I think you got it that's all you needed
yeah enigma
and there's no hidden blocks we gave uh
right here yeah that would uh
what do I do
Yamoto would have never done that
no okay this would definitely be in a
normal Mario game yeah yeah actually
part of me feels like Miyamoto would do
that because his big thing is reminding
you that video games are silly sure
Mario 2 the original yeah that's a
really tough game I I feel like I'm just
I'm going the same thing over and over
and over again so obviously that's not
working right
buttons I don't know about like no
there's no buttons you don't know about
[Music]
okay
I know I did a lot of these same things
Emma were you doing a lot of these same
attempts when you played this is not the
one that made me say I hate it oh okay
yeah why why
try that again
see if it's different this time yeah
yeah
okay it's just like a number of tries
right like five times in a row yeah
once you can hit number 42 yeah I was
thinking maybe I could go up or
something like there's some different
way I could go that isn't just through
that
whatever you're talking the right way
there's a difference I think this is the
one
[Applause]
oh it's six times you gotta do it six
times someone tell me what to do I gave
you the wrong number I'm sorry grub is
taking selfies okay the one thing I'll
tell you because I gave him
the area to the left you don't have to
worry about
like should I be going up
and if so how
okay they're thinking about the
different directions you can go in Mario
okay hold on
should I tell her how much time she has
left sure yeah do it you got a minute
20. minute 20. stop it how did I do that
before
[Music]
I don't know how to I don't know how to
intentionally recreate that motion
he's just having a party
this is his hole it was made for him oh
there are no invisible blocks that's
what you're going for there's none
oh my god really see Mario's house in
the Mario RPG where he just like lives
in a house in the Mushroom Kingdom I
don't know 50 seconds 50 seconds left
you got it
45 now remember the Enigma
yeah how do you get out of here can you
crack the junji Ito riddle
like I knew what I know the reference so
that's why I feel like going in the hole
is not a good idea yeah you generally
want to stay away from anything that
could vaguely be associated with a
spiral
when I go this way it does not seem like
a 20 seconds you got this 20 seconds go
that way I can't go that way
no hidden blocks
how did how did I make the spinny thing
happen what's the button that I do okay
this time it'll work
okay that's that's time
[Music]
and question what he's thinking yep
all right press start when you're ready
our final
I was feeling really confident
can't hold my earwax
no gross
yeah
we're just gonna change
so number one no invisible bra blocks
you don't have to worry about them oh
God
[Music]
okay
okay all right inevitable
you're very funny Dave I know that's why
I'm not a giant bomb
all right personal goodness we have to
destroy him now
no missable blocks no invisible blocks
three minutes grip
[Music]
all the different
around this point I believe I gave a
hint that they don't have to worry about
this area yeah
[Music]
you say that again you don't have to
worry about this area to the left all
right since everyone else got that hint
[Music]
s
just remember this is about dethroning
Dan
number one music's very
appropriate I feel it adds a nice
air of mystery yes it is a very
enigmatic level Mario World is my
favorite like tile set oh yeah
I'm just so legitimately interested to
see how you do this so I'm hoping that
rub figures it out because I wasn't able
to and I couldn't watch Dan figure it
out because I would have been cheated
[Music]
yeah there you go they're ready
thank you yeah
okay I'm used to eight
yeah I was thrown off am I allowed to
swear
I mean if you feel if the spirit moves
you yeah if the spirit moves you we we
encourage keeping it PG-13
we can't be held accountable for what
comes out of our own
rage
yeah I would have been able to figure
out
welcome grub to the house of illusions
there's three s's at me just press play
that's what's happening you got it
I hope this bike gives you flashbacks
[Music]
not at all
the focus
thank you
a total lack of trash talking happening
right now just in the zone
can I you know oh
sounds like it's going great so far so
good so far so good I think you're doing
great you are actually doing you are a
reigning Champion so far so all right I
have a lot of Fame
are there hidden blocks on this one
yes but not where you're at not this
area not yet
[Music]
changing colors
thank you
yeah they are kitchen colors aren't they
[Music]
okay all right very nice very nice Zone
he's in the zone
[Music]
collecting coins
playing very strategically right now I
have to say very careful yeah very
careful
[Music]
doesn't
you monster
so they're good enough rightfully you
have to trust what he's seeing with his
own eyes very helpful hidden block there
yes this is right
yep
[Music]
where are you
okay
[Music]
brutal
you have almost a minute and a half
remaining yeah
good
foreign
[Music]
one minute remaining
oh nice
[Music]
oh my God
getting down to the wire here yeah
20 seconds you got this you got this
speedrun
it is so possible kind of
[Music]
it was good at last attempt no idea
where to go all right so we're gonna
have Bailey or record now okay we'll do
Bailey next okay that's good because I
didn't put my arms down and I was about
to follow all right you're so cozy back
there start over Okay yep start over
and go ahead all right
and we're rocking races
hmm
yep
oh she's got it figured out
she got it already yeah
okay okay
[Music]
I fell but now up
on now yeah
I got it all right fair when I tested it
part of me thought maybe those aren't
really spikes maybe those were illusion
spikes okay I'm in here where's the
house of Illusions it could be it is
true
ouch illusion started
illusion snake version yeah yeah I just
like
okay all right okay I'm not gonna follow
this I'm gonna land where I wanna land
this is a big Improvement no spy kid no
spy kit big Improvement
progress as long as long as you're
making progress every time eventually
you'll get it yeah
[Music]
hey Dan you stink I know I know Dave I
have a lot of friends last night you're
making me look bad in front of all these
strangers
[Music]
I would have looked very bad
um
I figured out how to do this one but
lacked the Finesse to complete it
there are no invisible blocks in this
specific area yeah all right that's
right yeah there are hidden blocks but
they're not here in this area yeah
but that's a very helpful hint though
later no that is
that's helpful
but I don't know if it's gonna ever
apply to a couple maybe one or two
all right
close one
[Music]
I'm so proud of myself for figuring out
that one thing but now here I am not
able to get past it
it just seems to just try to get in
Dave's head think about
it you almost accidentally had it you
almost accidentally had it all right
great maybe it was in an accident maybe
I just right didn't you just get the job
yeah totally consider
okay
yeah I think if I wanted to do something
particularly wow
Dave
swear to God Dave I'm very proud of this
trick by the way this is it
a little bit the nice thing is at least
we warned you there were hidden blocks
yeah there they are very helpful found
them
well now you know
laughs
there you go yeah you got it
all right
it is particularly mean though because
you're like oh yes I got it I'm home
clear and then
you're not just the meanest thing yeah
I've ever done really just torture
[Music]
okay
yeah oh my God
[Music]
[Laughter]
how many are there yes yeah question
good question
[Music]
fine
you're further than me
like you don't trust anything no I don't
trust anything you really shouldn't yeah
there you go all right congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Dan
nice work yeah so when I said Yogurt yes
we're very close didn't believe in
myself yeah you were close to understand
the corrupt did not do it okay but he
still has a two minute about a minute
and a half lead on you so is this
cumulative I think so okay yeah okay let
me get this let's say yes all right
this
House of Illusions all right
[Music]
that's actually critically important to
opening this one okay
all right
I think I'm good
this time you have five minutes just so
you know okay grub failed Bailey
succeeded right yes okay yes got it
that's wrong
all right
all right I'm suspicious of everything
already
oh that was a problem okay
[Music]
don't think you can spin jump on that
stuff I think that's the Yoshi can go
across there
that's good
is that different wait I
wait hang on okay yep
that's got the one that goes like that
see if this has it
wait but those were
were those red
hang on Blue now
and they're gonna be red
he's learning colors everybody there we
go okay
differentiating between red and green
yes I know that Dan's a good game
journalist but I don't know if he'd win
smarter than a fifth grader yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna try that if I go in there flip
the thing it seems like it's a different
area yeah there's there's a
there's over here
I'm gonna drop down
yeah okay
[Music]
help us forward to the level yeah we
love a little a little Crouch jump oh
come on
that's some cat Mario crap yeah and this
classic Mario Maker yeah yeah yeah okay
so I think it's the other one
uh-huh so
right down here do one of these guys all
right
you flew right past that uh difficult
block situation you had before yeah
there we go
yeah knew that was gonna happen
oh come on it's gonna be really hard at
this point yeah
oh my God
we should say this is even right I hate
it yeah who's to say it's even right
[Music]
against points
is there any invisible blocks here Logan
you've already hit a bunch oh yeah
[Music]
oh that's where that store
all right
so mean that is the meanest part about
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't approve of that
two minutes left
okay do I have the fastest time on this
yeah because grub didn't finish it so oh
man
I didn't either when I was testing it to
be fair so don't feel bad about that I
feel really good now actually you're
basically a pro Mario yeah I I had to
redeem myself after the previous level
[Music]
is it possible after that uh yeah
what do we got going on here ah
[Music]
four minutes of this oh boy
and then just like cartoons this is
exactly where I like I think you're like
you're the Mario skills of just like one
minute I'm still like not sure actually
helped there yeah like you're like like
just not trust anything I think I'll
help you yeah all right yeah that's that
was where I failed I just couldn't
finesse those jumps
like again
right with a computer that was full of
literal insects that's unbelievable
back crap all right whatever I'll just
do this way
you need to understand Dave's process
before I could really get going
[Music]
why is that so much harder worried about
the guys
wait a minute
can I can I use that to my advantage how
much time do I have no 30 seconds
it's plenty of time yeah yeah you got
this I believe I won this one I'm so
happy
[Music]
oh
turtle
s so but you get stuck there for the
rest of your time
[Music]
and you had it right that was the way to
go up there hit the people in there
okay yeah okay all right that was it
It's Tricky all right she would go
Bailey will go first this time is it
great because every time I've held the
blindness in my face
for this one we've decided they don't
so they need to do it either way I mean
I feel like the surprise of seeing it
yeah let's do the Bible so let's still
do blind okay all right blindfolds you
can still gauge some strategy by
watching I agree yeah I totally agree do
we hear it
[Music]
yeah this is this conversation is
stressing me
well I lost my earbuds it is Mario Maker
so you know this is the final stage so
time to get your times back it also
makes sense that the winner went first
each time yeah oh yeah there you go
Dan hasn't won welcome forget it
he's first Kaizo baby's first Kaizo
great okay
all right here we go
[Music]
dad immediately dead yep all right okay
sounds like it's going well it's going
great it's going super good
all right
no I know I know okay I see it I just
have to like I just have to nail the
timing which is a different skill than
see
thank you
okay but I see it yeah
I believe in you thank you
it was good yeah I was getting there I'm
getting there yeah
[Music]
oh yeah no I did and it's not what you
want to do on this okay
[Music]
okay
Bailey's got a real stick-to-itiveness
about her yeah
we're gonna be defeated by freaking Dave
[Music]
use that anger yeah
thank you
the audience is giving you like golf
claps right now they believe in you yeah
no everyone everyone loves how much I
love to die
I'm really committed to just getting
just put yourself in a Mario space and I
think you got it that was annoying
everyone saw that that was very annoying
I think the whole thing is annoying yeah
it sure is okay
no I'm gonna get it this time this is
gonna be the one yep all right
nope it turns out it wasn't the next one
will be next one next one yeah when she
says this one she means whichever time
it works
oh okay you have the right idea
I have to yeah okay
you're gonna get it and you're gonna
feel so happy
yeah yeah maybe yeah I might get it and
then feel very happy I almost quoted
this this morning during uh voicemail
dump truck but I didn't want to you know
spoil anything about the level as my
proud gaming achievement
this is this is the work of someone who
gave a lot of anger
this is where I like to harness and put
all my anger puns are allowed in San
Diego right yeah you do this for fun
yeah
it's the timing is so precise it's very
precise if you believe it I actually
made it easier when I was testing it for
you guys oh well well look who's good at
video games
specifically
not me I'm talking about Dave I'm
terrible
wow but I did solve this and oh boy I'm
just gonna I I just I feel like I'm not
gonna get this one no hard you know be
one with 26 left so I think I think you
you can do it it is fine if I fail this
one because I'm the only one who did the
second one that's right and that one my
heels are there skills are improved
today that you
are great at maneuvering a jump okay you
might you might be in the lead yeah you
might be elite
in the lead in the lead oh yeah
yeah you kind of crushed that second one
thank you yeah I think that's true I
think Bailey is winning
really yeah you're winning she's doing
this other one so fast yeah I did do the
second one pretty fast
but for me
I did I'm not doing this one although
that's the first one really quick so
actually I'm making like a negative uh
improvements here making deep movements
no that you you're doing the right thing
yeah I'm just not getting the timing
it's the execution
30 seconds good I'm gonna get it
oh David
[Music]
all right I believe you have one more
attempt making one more test it's gonna
be the one I can
[Music]
again
okay well played well played I tried so
hard I just I really want are you ready
uh you want them to do it because I want
to see anything okay yeah but I also
want to win so I don't want them to do
it okay
I'm very torn there are 12s inside
and we don't want you to see this rub
has the look of determination it's the
look of a winner
[Music]
all those years of training grub this is
where they count
[Music]
I feel like just quitting there I was
like I'm actually gonna play something
else
if we just looked at this level and said
nah
[Music]
hmm
I believe in you
don't let your shirt down
[Music]
oh Punk
yep it's actually it's good to get
killed by each of them then it's lucky
yeah then then you've you're you've
truly accomplished what this level is
meant to accomplish which is just to die
in many ways as possible yeah
my goal with this segment is have less
Friends by the end oh yeah yeah
[Music]
actually the second stage with those
hidden blocks when you were tempting me
with the door is when I actually said I
hate you but that's what made the ladder
start too I know you find the last I
know
it's so true
[Music]
as you feel better watching grub also
struggle with this
this is hard you have to
nail the timing for the whole time to
start blaming the controller this d-pad
isn't very good yeah that sucks
you're getting it that's about as hard
as I was able to get on it
[Music]
not sure if I should run or not
you shouldn't don't don't no you're
doing the right thing
yeah I'll tell you don't run it makes it
harder okay all right yeah this is a uh
uh expert maneuvering
kind of pure timing and skill
Dave out of curiosity is there more to
this level
yes
but this is the hardest part so yeah
okay
I it makes me feel me feel a lot better
watching everyone have the exact same
experience with this level that I did
when I tested it
so I have another level I made where
this is just in the middle of a level oh
so at least like this is the start get
it over with yeah that's great yeah very
generous of you
[Music]
it was considerate to put this at the
very beginning yeah just get it out of
the way
[Music]
oh you're getting it you're getting it
okay
foreign
[Music]
yeah the frustrating part is when you
figure out what you're supposed to do
and you just still can't do it yeah
yeah you know what you're supposed to do
yeah
very clear oh and then when you actually
pull it off dang
I say when because I believe if
[Music]
it's one minute left you got one minute
you got this oh boy oh boy
[Music]
you know I put another obstacle in just
in case and I'm like that was a mistake
[Music]
then the hidden block right at the end
that is that that is actually the most
treacherous part
[Music]
boom
once you get past there yeah
[Music]
yes come on so close
you have two attempts left
the pressure
's one of those ones who does better in
pressure
[Music]
it's gonna be the one I just this is the
one this is the run I can feel it
power of the Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
okay
yep out of curiosity none of us can do
it I do want to watch David yeah if
Nobody Does It dude's got it all right
Dan yeah
no pressure here I mean I can't beat it
so you have to beat it okay all right
the d-pad I did hear you say that about
the d-pad it is not a good d-pad I
wouldn't use the analog uh no no I'm not
a maniac
all right
yeah four or five here five minutes here
five okay all right
you got this you got this you got this
yes oh that's bad
okay it's gonna happen several times
did anyone get past this part no no oh
good okay
okay
trying to figure out which one to try to
go between there I tried to make them
all the exact same fire he thinks it's
bad and doesn't like it
uh oh man yeah
sprinting seems dangerous
yeah that seems like instant fiery death
as opposed to
cautious fieriness sucks this sucks that
sucks I don't like this I tried to just
walk though and it's like that also
didn't feel great
[Music]
I do appreciate that I will tell you
that running is a bad idea
does something I'm like I just like the
feel of the Mario jumping so I didn't
have to make myself feel better yeah no
it's nice to play a little like an hour
it's really threading the needle there
yeah it is what if I just pulled right
at the beginning does that work no yes
nope nope
I gotta test everything out here
and it says yes
okay okay okay okay okay okay go go go
down
has anyone gotten like halfway that's
where we are going everybody made it to
the halfway yeah they made it like just
fast okay
nope nope okay
that's what happened to me is that I
forgot the feeling and then they kept
coming down on my head
trying to figure out where I can stand
here will that when I was testing it I
tried to figure out for myself
sucks
I'm like where in the ark above I should
run in below yeah you're right there's
fine there it is
you're getting the entrance really well
though yeah yeah yeah
I think I can line up like halfway into
this hill that'll miss me
wait what happens if I oh that closes it
off okay yep that's bad yep
hey yeah there's you just have to go
through it yeah there's no way around
that's rough yeah it is
now I just want to see someone do it do
it Dan I don't know the good thing is I
really love it it's 15 seconds
yeah we're just in a in a constant music
Loop
[Music]
foreign
they just like come down so much faster
than you're thinking yeah they do come
down faster than you think
what am I doing
d-pad d-pad I know that's right that's
d-pad it's the it's totally the d-pad
yeah do you even test this is this
regulation Dave oh I can't beat it
oh I know I I made sure they were all
right yeah
I play I played it with joy-con I was
like Emma got through it but it took her
she took me a long time yeah but I got
through it last night damn it
so you remember that part of last night
when we were having a conversation
I was laser focused on this
blindfolded Dan oh God
here we go
now I'm just gonna say that if you get
through it that's the end of the stage
yeah that's it that's the end probably
like the later ones like those sort of
that middle one okay
[Music]
maybe is a little bit more grace okay
gotta go earlier maybe when it's like
parallel maybe that's when I start
walking let me see
all right so I'm gonna watch that last
one
there it is all right yeah so when
that's about parallel you can start
moving it's going to be changing speed
right because it's like you're getting
closer to the center and so it's going
to be going slower than faster you kind
of have to like walk stop it's like
variable it's really deceptive because
it seems like they should all be going
try like tapping oh yeah
Feathering it yeah buffer inputs yeah
yeah
man
[Music]
Dan do it for the people 20 seconds you
got this you got this no pressure yes
[Music]
technically that's your final attemption
oh yeah
all right here we go that's brutal
[Music]
whoa oh all right one more and then we
can probably have to wrap this up a
really exciting thing next
[Music]
he goes for the second to the last
one
[Applause]
oh yeah you gotta jump off of this okay
that oh my God damn damage boost oh my
God
all right
[Music]
amazing amazing work all right everybody
thank you so much congratulations to our
winner
Bailey's well done whoa and Bailey
why don't you stick around for well as
my prize for being the winner I am now
about to interview the voice cast of God
of War so stick around for some of that
thanks everybody and stick around
everybody thank you on Twitch thank you
so much to all of our Giant Bomb
colleagues for including us thank you
this weekend and thank you to dreamhack
for having us don't go anywhere we'll be
right back
never imagine
[Music]
come on
this
trying to do so far from each other
[Music]
What a Wonderful World
for
eign
[Music]
[Applause]
the sky
[Music]
remember today
foreign
[Music]
saving the last time
everybody I don't oh there we go hello
everyone welcome back to the main stage
here at dreamhack San Diego
2023. once again yes Woo is is the
energy that we want to bring to this all
right
fantastic my name is Emma Fife I am a
senior video producer at fandom I am
going to ultimately be your chat
moderator Monitor and audience question
taker later in our panel today so start
ruminating in your mind if you have any
questions that you might want to ask the
cast of God of War Ragnarok that we have
here with us today but first of all I'm
going to step aside and into my duty of
monitoring the live chat which for the
record I'm mostly on giant bombs twitch
because y'all are popping off over there
uh let me bring to the stage my
colleague who is going to be moderating
this panel for us today Bailey Myers son
hello hello I feel like I just saw all
of you but you look so much more
beautiful now now that I'm in this chair
the chair for the questioner so we are
going to be talking to the voice cast of
God of War Ragnarok we should let's
bring them out everybody
[Music]
they're coming it's a long walk
they gotta get all the way here from
Northland
and it's so far away
there we go here they come
guys
big big Applause hi Bailey Myers nice to
meet you hello hello everyone get comfy
sit where you like we've got microphones
you know otherwise you know
great yeah we'll have can everyone fit
on the couches or can we squish between
some of the chairs
yeah no it's just like that uh this is
uh the episode where Ross Rachel Phoebe
and everyone learn to speak uh ancient
Scandinavian yeah it did feel like a
friend's moment
happy Easter yes a big happy things
happening yeah big Miracles here all
right why don't we all go down the line
and introduce ourselves to start at the
very end hi I'm Alistair Duncan and I
play mimir in God of War
hi I'm Evan Friedman and I play gnaw in
God of War which you probably only know
if you're very good at the game
hi my name
hello hi Adam Harrington and I play
cindry
hi I'm Marla gorendona and I'm Bella
hey there Danielle basuti I play Freya
Queen of the Valkyries Queen of the
Valkyries uh hi I'm Ben Prendergast and
I play Tear can I get a boo
[Music]
so wonderful to
me a lot of questions both from the
fandom communities and from my own heart
I'm a big fan of the game I have got to
say I know gnaw and I'm so mad at you
I'm so sorry you should be you should be
but I'm so excited to talk to all of you
I think the very first thing we have to
get out of the way start from the
beginning how did we all get into
character how did we get come to embody
the roles that we wound up playing I
chopped my head off oh yeah okay well
you did a great job reattaching really
good uh sewing foreign
music for me music really really helps
what were we listening to
God of War Music well yeah a lot of
Norse music just things that are a
little bit heavier because Gana is this
incredible
not I'm not that so that's what I did
uh
I I for 2018 I I knew people that were
germaphobic ah uh so I was able to pull
a bit from that and then Ragnarok was a
whole other Rabbit Hole to go down a lot
of it for me just kind of came from the
script I thought the story was so
amazing yeah I think your character goes
through such a drastic change by the end
like you had a lot you really had to a
lot of emotions I think you had to
embody so well beyond germaphobia there
was that and what they told me uh going
into Ragnarok was that this is going to
be a mild spoiler yeah everyone please
be prepared for spoilers in this one how
could there not be they told me that
cindry would take his gloves off
and then then that they said that he'll
have Brock's blood on his armor and I
said does he ever wash the blood off and
they said no
so I thought well that's
that's super heavy so I I kind of just
went back from there really incredible
let's keep going
wow that's very profound I also
um listen to music hi lung was my music
of choice
um and I also
um just having the visual like knowing
what she looks like ahead of time and I
was also lucky enough to do a lot of the
previous for the game as well so I kind
of got a good sense of the story that
way ahead of time so before day of so
that was very lovely very lovely treat
that's wonderful and I'm also just
generally dark anyways she's a she's a
moody Warrior it helps see that about
you as well
Danielle I know that Freya went through
a lot of changes so I probably even more
so than sindri did uh how were you able
to get into the role in the mindset for
each of different stages she went
through in the game
yeah there's I don't think there's any
emotion spared through freya's Journey
um you know and for so just for me as an
actress it was what can I pull from my
real life to fulfill this narrative in a
way that would honor her to the deepest
level and yeah so there were moments
where I sort of isolated myself uh oh
you didn't really want to be not
necessarily around me during these
moments because it I wanted to make it
so personal I mean she's Outcast to
grieving her son to full Vengeance and
then finally understanding that her
choices led her to this moment in her
life which I think is so incredible and
I could maybe speak for everyone on this
stage like we were honored to be part of
one of the most brilliant narratives and
a narrative that was so responsible with
an ethos of you can choose to be better
but first take responsibility for your
life and when she finally gets that
um I just was weeping that day when the
scene with the norns and spoiler and she
finally realizes okay this Vengeance and
all of these emotions she had to go
through by the way that's the humanity
piece of Frey on all these characters
they humanize these Gods to make them
relatable and my heart was ripped out
and I was like all right well this is
the pathway to sovereignty and peace and
it doesn't look like getting revenge it
looks like giving it to myself on my own
terms and finally coming to terms with
all that I am and I and I had to just
re-injure myself as Danielle through the
process to fulfill that and finally find
peace so it was very thorough experience
and music actually helped me a lot too a
lot of different things in my playlist
Tory Amos was one of the big Muses for
me in this process so I love that I feel
very Tori Amos vibes from Freya
and I guess fatia
um I'm not going to give any spoilers in
case people haven't played the game
obviously we're going to talk about
so if you haven't played the game and
you're afraid of spoilers that you
really should leave but yeah so tears
playing two there's a duality to tear
obviously but I never ever wanted anyone
to know what was going on until the
moment
um but also from a law point of view
you've got the Norse god of war so he
has to match with Kratos on some level
energetically
um and also but he's more of a peaceful
God so that was easy to justify what Tia
was doing in terms of being a pacifist
and not wanting to you know head off to
um Ragnarok
um but also knowing that there was a
second a secondary internal thing that
was happening from the other guy
um and so that was great writing great
Direction
also I'm walking around the performance
capture stage um with someone with a
pole behind me with my face at eight
foot five and my eyeline was to
everyone's crotch so you know that's
um that's a benefit to acting to tear
but um yeah anyway yeah
you can keep that I promise I've got my
own it's attached to my face
so what was everyone's favorite line of
dialogue to record I know mimir had more
lines than probably we anyone here knows
about yeah ten thousand that's ten
thousand likes he was like a high number
but I can't tell if you're exaggerating
or if that's just the real number he
sucks so much he just talks and talks
and talks until everybody falls asleep
what I'm gonna do to you
um yeah I mean
bollocks brother
that was one of my favorites
and after my head's been cut off and I'm
showing my body hanging in the tree I'd
say that's a sight that no man should
ever have to see so that was good and
there were lots there were lots where I
insulted people you know calling Thor a
sweaty ball bag
that was good I like that line uh and
then just being smart and and all but
one of my favorite ones was when I
worked out what Brock's
um riddle was that I couldn't work it
out
and I go ah a hole and it just it was
because of what had just happened in the
scene and there was so much wonderful
emotion that had come from from Adam and
from Danielle and it just and it just
got me because it was I'd lost somebody
out we'd lost somebody we loved and we
really did I mean we all actually like
each other we actually really enjoy
spending time with each other so it was
actually meaningful all of those
emotional scenes were so meaningful to
all of us yeah that's really wonderful
has a lot of uh Power powerful lines
I've heard a lot of them or Asgard
not anyone's favorite line oh gosh I'm
I'm gonna beat you one day you haven't
no I'm sorry I hear it's very hard my
sister hates the line for Asgard for
Asgard for Asgard and I understand why
now yeah my favorite line of dialogue is
I mean the first line
um in the cut scene if you beat Gana
um working with Danielle is fantastic
and uh they have this really beautiful
back story
um which is another part of preparation
Matt is incredible the writer Matt sofos
and their relationship is so beautiful
and sad and Danielle brought up bringing
up responsibility having responsibility
for yourself Genna is the one who didn't
do that and let anger
take that and the first line she says is
you would judge me
to uh to freyja and it just it breaks my
heart but that was my favorite line that
I got to say so good
sindri also has a lot of great lines
obviously true but I'm gonna take this
opportunity to speak on behalf of Robert
Craighead who wanted to be here and
unfortunately had to leave due to work
this morning so I'm gonna say my
favorite line is pretty much anything
out of his mouth as Brock
right absolutely that man could read the
phone book as Brock and it would be
funny
and he loves doing it he has this
cracking up constantly at dinner last
night
ordering drinks is Brock
so
Bowser Brock yeah
incredible
yeah I'm so I I so wish he could have
been here but it's so great having
everyone here today I'm so excited to
talk to all of you I love to know what
one of what bayla's best line to you was
um you know there's this
word that Bella utters in the boat scene
when the incomparable Jim Perry delivers
his lines and it was
um it was just his character's name and
I during rehearsal during the recording
of it
the big moment and I said his name wrong
I was like ah
like
I was like oh
but it was
um when we got it right it was uh it was
wonderful because he himself as an actor
is just
so um
he just kind of didn't make he didn't he
was didn't make a fuss he did never he
never really said much at all and then
in that scene and he delivers this
gorgeous monologue like where did you
come from
it was beautiful and then that I mean it
was just gorgeous it was a gorgeous
moment
that moment of sacrifice is so well done
in the game and definitely Bayless just
genuine sorrow in that moment is so it's
so compelling it really like even if
these are not characters you were like
hanging out with the whole time you
really understood the gravity of what
was happening and
absolutely so well done
Danielle the commitment level of every
actor honestly in this game was just
absolutely staggering and would just rip
your heart out I mean
there was something very special that
happened every time we stepped in the
volume and we talk about it a lot like
there was a sacred energy that happened
I could every time I looked into every
single actor's eyes they were present
they were there they care about the
narrative they care about these
characters and we and we believe that's
why they've impacted the fans and The
Gamers so deeply because we were feeling
those feelings genuinely I think for
Freya it would be um in the first game
obviously my promise to rain down every
Agony and every violation imaginable
upon you and every time I would be
parade as cold body in every corner of
every realm feed his soul to the vile is
filth in hell that's my promise and it
just ripped my heart out every single
time and it was written for me just to
just tear into it and it ripped my heart
out um and then to make good on that
promise on the downbeat of Ragnarok you
know just I'm I am after his [__]
head you know what I want it and I was
like this feels so appropriate to
deliver
um but then I would say in Ragnarok that
when I spoiler
forgive him in a sense but in a really
honest way it reminded me of Maggie in
The Walking Dead because when she comes
to terms
um
why am I going to forget his name right
now uh Negan thank you everyone I am
Negan I am Negan
she still has that pain and anger that's
that was you know that was her love
Baldur was my son and there's a piece of
her that would always be angry
but she realizes it's not him and then I
think the completion of that would be
when I finally have the opportunity to
get that Vengeance and annihilate who I
think my enemy is Odin right you know
with the Noose and everything I you have
no hold on me anymore with my wings and
finally she's at such calm and
sovereignty and peace to say
I don't need this anymore to make me
whole and I and I and I remembered I was
like should I be crying should I be
weeping what is this moment and thank
God for Eric Williams our brilliant
director because he was like I think
this is just so simple you've already
gone through every range of emotion
possible you have arrived you don't need
this anymore I would say that that was
um those were some of my favorite
moments for for that's really amazing
Ben tier has a lot of
really funny moments as well as uh
unless decidedly less funny moments yes
which ones were you vibing with
um so I think in uh difference to the
great uh Robert
um Craighead I think my favorite tier
line was one that's set up for one of
his lines and it was the big moment
where Tia we were finally gonna get the
tier god of war and he's like you know
um I know I've been a burden to you all
I know you've questioned why I even came
here I know I have too but it's clear
now this is why I'm here yada yada and
he goes um he goes uh so one more time
I'll pick up my Spear and I will lead us
to Asgard hold on you damn spruce
that is it's like he's in the room with
us that's incredible where is he
everyone's got a brock I think we need
to hear everyone's Brock
I just got some [__] gratitude
I'm not even gonna give it a shot that's
fair it's fair you don't have to what
the hell are you all looking at anyway
oh my gosh I spent a lot of time no I
don't have one I'll hurt myself
what the [__] is going on here
so basically just growl and swear yeah
technique all right
we now all know how to be Brock that's
fantastic
uh on us on a very serious note this is
something that someone in the community
really really wanted to know
if you were unceremoniously have if you
unceremoniously had your soul shoved
into the body of a giant snake what's
the first thing you would do
I'll say
if you had your soul shoved into the
body of a giant snake like what happens
in Ragnarok atreus puts one of the giant
souls into a snake
what would you do
what would I do if I suddenly basically
became a giant snake yeah it's one of
the more seriousness scare the [__] out
of the people I don't like
I would I would I would
I just have whatever fun I could as a
snake yeah you know I'd find some other
snakes and you know go for a drink or
something and you know have a good time
yeah that's a simple life
[Laughter]
good
go into
some water yeah and I'd swim around as a
little snake I don't know what would you
do as a snake you know I think that's
what the snake does in the game so is
that what happens is it a water snake he
gets big and he goes into the water
there must be some friends in there
you're on the same wavelength of the
snake same snake length oh I know
exactly what I would do then I would
just go to sleep oh yeah I just love to
sleep that sounds nice
I think I'd have to like call
[Music]
them sort of ritual situation I don't
know I think there's I think there's
hope I think there's something there's a
positive at the end yeah
I'll double down on that I would Slither
my way to the world tree
and I would have a conversation with
ratatosk or my favorite squirrel and I
would try to figure out how do we repair
these nine realms
like what kind of world serpent Voodoo
can I do to bring to broker a piece
which is obviously because if I was
Freya inside a snake which is the world
serpent that's probably what she would
want to do well that would be the most
powerful snake anyone's ever met and
she'd have wings as well yes
uh that's an easy one for an Australia
and I guess we'd get two first-class
flights to uh on Qantas back to
Melbourne probably go under a bit of tin
find another snake raise a little snake
family go fishing you know just live The
Good Life
that sounds so nice
I love it
little Aussie your manga love it
[Laughter]
okay now we have to talk about the twist
okay everyone if you haven't played the
game there's a pretty big twist that
happens about two-thirds of the way
through right uh when spoiler alert it's
turned out the tears been lying to us
the whole time
what did we all think of the big lie
let's start what's here we'll go with
reverse order uh well I found out about
a big lie before we actually shot all of
Ragnarok I think I got through like one
session before they actually pulled me
aside and said um
Hey listen you you're always going to be
tear you know you you've developed a
fantastic character but we just need to
let you know that you are Odin as well
in Disguise
and so I'm just like for five minutes
just like
um and uh and so that was a tough moment
obviously a tough moment I knew I was
about to become the most hated character
in the game and
um
uh God it was just a really tough moment
but also a really exhilarating moment
trying to pull that off for the for the
for the gamers really
um and so I could never ever in any
choice that Tia made throughout the game
I could never make Odin's Choice even
though every choice tier made was Odin
in the background I could never ever
pretend in my own mind that I was Odin
because I would have given something
away because everything is so accurately
captured from us from our facial
expressions to where we look but then
when you go back and play the game I've
dropped a lot of Easter eggs in that
performance so you can see what's
happening whether he's literally
stirring the pot while Kratos and atreus
are talking or whatever it is I put a
few things in there for him that's
fantastic did everyone know about the
twist in advance or were you the only
one that they told
yeah we knew we were told that's great
and the fun thing actually was watching
uh Ben's performance was actually
watching him do these shows because
there's really there's moments there's
such subtle part just just a momentary
pause
a little smile or something that's there
that you go when you look at it when you
look back at it and you go oh oh he
looks like he's happy about this yeah
there was one moment I think it around
the dinner table and um Eric uh the
director Williams came up to me and he's
like I'm watching you Prendergast it's
like I can see you eyeing atreya stuff I
can see you looking at Sunny until you
just see Tia sitting there during the
dinner Kratos is over there and Sonny
was there and I just remember on the day
just being like
ready to steal him away you know very
predatory
incredible very much very much a snake
amongst us is what you were oh and and I
I I totally Echo what Aleister said it
was I can't remember exactly when we
found out but then knowing that and just
watching Ben's performance because it
was interesting when he would be so
agreeable with what was going on and
then just ever so slightly sleight of
hand turn us a different direction and
it was it was quite masterful
um and I think the way uh that I felt
about that as Freya was just when when
it landed the the amount of betrayal
that Freya has experienced in her
journey is just time and time again and
when I find out this whole time I've
been speaking Yeah my ex has literally
been like you know right in the room
next to me right there at the dinner
table hearing all of my hatred and
hearing all of my plans to to try to
destroy him um yeah it was just yet
another dagger in my heart and then what
that led to of course not being able to
save Brock and looking into Adam's eyes
as he's weeping over our beloved Brock
was just um yeah just ripped my heart
out
um I I remember being told like like in
the previous portion of things and like
having it blocked out and they wouldn't
say it outright but like the previous
team kind of like China figure it out
and stuff it and then when I realized
we're like oh my God
so
stunning we all were just
took our breath away but yeah it was
kind of it was wild it was wild we
how do I feel about Odin oh I mean I
think it's pretty clear from your
performance how you feel about it killed
Odin yeah
and you deserved it that's how I feel
about Odin don't get them into my house
and kill my brother with my own knife
it's rude first of all that's all I got
to say about that
[Laughter]
fan thought that was awesome
way to go go Odin tier nice way to go
as Evan
so such a heartbreaking scene I mean
Adam and Robert
crushed me in that moment
um beautiful and horrible
horrible
um but yeah huge fan
[Laughter]
Alistar what did you think of the twist
I thought I'd said uh um uh yeah uh
shock horror yeah shock I'm the smartest
man in the world and I have missed the
most obvious thing and I've given away
all of I mean like it's just it's an
awful moment because I basically I'm not
a complete idiot I feel like complete
idiot at that moment yeah but I didn't
say anything forces so nobody knows
right afterwards mamir was just like
yep
so yeah all makes sense to me when you
were all preparing for your characters
how did you arrive at the voice you
chose to use because I you know Alistair
obviously you have you are Scottish
can you tell Scottish so I I think I can
guess that but like how the affectations
that we all choose to use when we do
these roles but we I mean you all the
professional voice actors hypothetically
um
I'm not phrasing it well forgive me
everybody how did you arrive at your
voices
it was simple yes I am Scottish it's not
my his accent is his Scottish accent is
not my accent and it was a combination
of a glass wheat in it also because he
is a he is a creature of the um the
forest of the uh the wilds and so it was
a partially a an accent from the islands
and from the the so it became you know
like there was there's definitely a
glass region which is sort of like that
you know very very glottal and very very
harsh and then from the islands it's
more it's a far later accent and so it
was somewhere in between the two and it
just it just worked it was like I did it
and then I was like okay that's it I've
got it yeah I know he is
Evan how did you arrive at NAS voice wow
uh great question you know there's so
many different ways actors come to that
uh exact question and there's an actor
who is um in God of War named Chris
Browning and I spoke to him about it he
just placed his own voice in everything
and and it's so fantastic he's so
fantastic in the game it allows for like
all of the subtlety to come out
when I first started voice acting I went
how do they do that they do that
um with Gana she has a chip on her
shoulder
she's had it for a long enough she wants
to
portray strength she's hiding pain and
the little girl who feels left so you'd
build for me it was like build you know
be strong deep voice you know protect my
emotion and not let any of it come
through
Cindy had so many different voices
um
I think for 2018
I thought that somebody who is wants to
be giving like that and needy and wants
everyone to laugh all the time so his
voice pitches up a bit there's a couple
of moments where I think you hear how
cindry probably really sounds as one
when he confronts Kratos when he finds
the ax and then a lot of moments where
he's alone in Ragnarok
but then after the event
he kind of gets back in touch with his
own rage and stuff and isn't just so
forgiving and nice all the time and you
hear his voice start to drop yeah
and that when it just gets more rageful
and
it's just a blind and then by the end he
has no voice except to whisper to Brock
because he's just done so I'm gonna cry
again and happy
Bela bayla's voice how did we get there
so so often when I do a like a dark type
character it tends to you know it's
pitched down but it tends to be very
has a Melody to it that feels like
Conjuring but Bayla is different than
any of those so I used like uh big beers
like a counterpart knowing that his was
going to have this lightness to it and
hearing
um what that voice is going to be like
so I could be a counter
uh like a Counterpoint to that and
um he was warm and loving and so I would
be
Steely and Stern and
curmudgeonly but you know uh but but
this strength we both had like a shared
anger but
um you know he he processes it
differently than I do and so I feel like
I can be the anger for both of us and so
I would be that
I carry that in my voice that's so
interesting I loved that
Daniel how did you get to Freya it took
me a minute to find her and I think
because you know I'm very studious when
I get a role when I found out I didn't
even know what game I was in until the
table read
and then I didn't realize I was actually
playing the Norse goddess Freya until I
sat at the table which of course made me
freak out I'm like I'm in the theater
and I would have prepared uh so yeah I
didn't know at first I didn't know her
journey and I think
probably for most actors once you're
connected to the emotional Journey
whatever that might be for your
character The Voice the movement comes
out so it was a journey for me to find
her and I was at first playing her a
little too Regal because I'm like but
she's the Norse goddess she's the queen
of The Valkyrie the leader of the
vannier and I remember they kept wanting
me to just pull back from that and one
time Corey came up to me in 2018 the
2018 game and he was like you know kind
of like she's been through it all seen
that done that doesn't care you know
like a little bit like Han Solo I'm some
of you may have heard this story so it's
like Han Solo whoa so that night I swear
to God I had a dream and Han Solo came
to me
now I am a Star Wars nerd so this isn't
completely out of the ordinary and he
was just like I was just hanging out
with Han Solo and I was getting his
mannerisms and kind of like you know
like when she goes I'm still a God go
away you know like she didn't have
anything to prove because everything had
already been taken from her and it was
all about rebuilding who she is on her
own terms so once I got her starting
point
and the back story that was supporting
that all the other colors came out and I
would I would just say one last thing it
much like Adam was saying how the voice
changes depending on what uh who she's
with
when I see atreus and when I'm with
atreus her voice pitches up to that
loving mother and and just her heart
opens up he sort of represents that son
that she's been longing for and the
repair that she's been hoping to create
in her life so I did enjoy those scenes
with him of course in Ragnarok not so
much as 2018 but at the end of Ragnarok
I return back to that softer uh Freya
voice yeah
I love that the um at the end of
Ragnarok when Kratos is like I love you
and you're like I know
that's the post game I like I'm willing
it to happen in the third one I'm
willing it to happen
um I think for tear obviously I already
had a fairly high profile Australian
character sorry 100 wanted tear to be
American I also knew he was the Norse
god of Norse god of war so I wanted to
have him as a counterpart to Kratos but
he's also the God of Peace so you know
at first um you know tear was much lower
and he was down here and and I don't
think that really matched with what they
wanted and so tear had to become much
more rounded and up here and maybe a
little higher pitch and and also I
wanted him to be kind of um a vuncular
you know an uncle to atreyas a secondary
father and what I loved about Tia the
real tier is um that in essence he kind
of is the is the battle against toxic
masculinity in a sense you know a strong
male figure who isn't about using your
fists or using your weapons it's about
what other way can we find to move
through this world that isn't about as
testosterone driven thing you know
um and but then knowing what we all know
had to happen it was just it felt like
the right move to have him quite rounded
and soft and easy and you would never
suspect him in a million years to be the
person who ultimately rips your heart
out
and then he was
then he was
um so that's how I came to that
um but you know and then and then
afterwards they're like well let's
record the sessions where spoilers sorry
let's let's record the sessions where
you find the real tier and I remember
talking to Matt and I was like hey well
maybe this is the opportunity to make
the real tier Australian and they're
like no that's a [__] idea
so you know you know the the real tear
is uh he's in there just like not
knowing what the hell happened I've just
been locked up in here and Odin did what
and where's Odin he's wait he's dead and
like where was I where someone was
pretending to be me so uh yeah
that's excellent I you can really hear
it it's he seems so unassuming so the
Odin surprise I think really does
deliver well because he just seems like
a literal gentle giant I think you play
that very well
um I have been told we have time for
some audience questions
and by some I really do mean like a
couple a couple so what we're going to
do is Bailey you pick a couple people
from the audience to come up four
questions you are gonna have to come up
on the stage because I can't come down
to you with my microphone nobody will be
able to hear you the channel doesn't
extend that far but I am going to ask a
couple of questions uh from twitch chat
in the meantime so raise your hand if
you have a question Bailey picked two
people and a few notes we are not we
can't do any questions where you're
asking for advice on breaking into the
voice acting industry we won't be taking
those anything else though yeah so if
you have questions raise your hand
Bailey we'll show you where to go you
got to go safely up these stairs but in
the meantime um since we were talking
about the Odin of it all uh hidden SLV
wants to know Ben did you talk to
Richard or watch his Odin performance
and did it influenced here
I didn't need to because Richard's one
of my favorite actors I knew what he
sounded like what he how he behaved um
and had and suspected that's where he
would go because they would had a good
idea of what the story involved um met
him early on uh and knew for that
specific sort of pivotal scene that um
that he would be taking off from my
performance so um
I think he was an amazing Odin um uh it
made it really easy for me to sort of
slot him with that but we really didn't
need to your question collaborate as
closely as you would think because I'm a
huge fan
um of his anywhere and you you were just
doing his work so synergistic to begin
with you just slid right into it oh yeah
despite the lack of actually Australian
tier sorry that that pitch didn't work
out for you
um Daniel I think you were touching on
this a little bit um FL style and chat
wanted to know about how having that
sort of motion capture experience are
capturing your your facial experiences
and you do get to group record how that
is different than maybe your like
standard standing in front of a
microphone voice acting gig
well fortunately most of what we did was
performance capture so it's basically
like theater right because you're taking
the scene from beginning middle and end
which is really quite wonderful it I I
would venture to say it's even more
challenging in a voice over Booth uh
because you're sort of in a dark space
and you're creating these emotions on
your own I mean it is a whole other
Talent set that goes with that but um
really I think it's just getting
comfortable with the hardware right
because we've got these helmets that are
heavy with a camera on a craned piece of
metal in your face you have basically an
entire outfit that has Velcro on it so
you're constantly I mean I don't know
about you guys I was constantly getting
stuck on myself you know you've got
these little tiny markers and then you
have the audio pack around your waist so
the short version is once you could stop
feeling that on your body you could
really anger yourself in the presence of
the scene and I for myself personally it
took me a moment to get used to it but
then after a while it became like Second
Skin and we were just there alive in the
moment acting out these beautiful scenes
together
amazing all right well I think we're
ready to take our first audience uh
questions so why don't you come on over
here young man
uh I think you have a little bit of a
personal connection to this group up
here Could you um let the people know
who you are
well I am Marla gordona's son or Baylor
and my question is how do you think your
characters relate to others
that's well thank you for the question
kind sir
um you know I think I think Bayla as
well as big beer are um they're kind of
Outsiders they have their own they're
part of a team that is very much
separate from everyone else
um but I think uh
they understood the cause and decided to
be a part of it they rallied all
together and uh and they showed up and
they did their best
thank you very much for the question
and uh you should not be upstairs here
be careful
[Laughter]
all right we have another uh member of
the audience coming to join us right
this way sir
hello what is your name hi my name is
Jason and Jason what is your question
yeah I wanted to ask you guys about
um the audition process when you guys
first got the script what kind of
character choices did you make on that
character that stuck and what kind of
things did you have to change
uh when I first heard of um Tia it was
um almost like a sergeant-at-arm so I
came into the room like Brad Pitt from
Inglorious Bastards I was like I will
get my scarves and that wasn't here at
all luckily they brought me back
um and the big issue they had with me
was because I'm a personable guy is that
I was too nice and so at the end of my
audition uh Matt I think it was was like
Hey Ben just to choose someone from up
here because you're you're down there
and there's like 20 people here just
like looking at your performance like
choose someone just to like just to you
know have it out with them you know chew
them out a bit which is the hardest
thing for an actor because you want to
like please everyone and so to turn on
someone from Santa Monica Studio was
tough and I did it to such a degree that
I I scared myself and thought that I'd
blown at 100 blown it uh literally told
them where to go literally turn around
in a half told Eric to stop effing
laughing because it's not effing funny
ran out of the room and then got out of
the room and I was like what the hell
did I just do
but I booked it
should we pass down yeah go ahead short
version uh it was a beautiful speech It
Felt Like a Lady Macbeth or a Khaleesi
Mother of Dragons I I didn't know what I
was auditioning for I knew it was an
interactive game and it was a queen who
had lost everything so I thought well
I've studied Shakespeare Theater let's
just give him my you know lady Stark and
uh and I ended up booking it Corey said
within the first 30 seconds he knew I
was as Freya which is every actor's
dream because you walk into every
audition thinking it's mine and this
this time it it truly was just uh right
so that's amazing
I I guess my audition was doing previous
but my funny kind of story about the
audition is I was already working uh
doing the performance capture for Bayla
and I got an audition for
God of War Ragnarok and was like should
I can I so I auditioned for the role of
a Berserker owl and then I booked that
as well as well
fantastic
um I didn't know it was God of War all
they told me I was auditioning for a guy
who's uh afraid of germs and you're
bringing people across a river on a raft
but you don't want to bring them across
but one of them has an ax that you made
go
and then but to answer your question I
didn't have the voice The Voice wasn't
there yet that came once I met Robert
and also once I saw what syndra looked
like and I didn't also realize in the
audition that he was going to be that
short so all that stuff kind of came
after
uh my my uh I didn't have an audition
actually this was a very interesting
story The Incredible Danielle basuti and
I had worked on a film together uh just
before Ragnarok had come out yes he
played my mom which you might find to be
unbelievable
um but what I found out was Matt was
looking for someone that Danielle had
worked with had an instant connection
with because ganah was only coming in
for a single day and there had to be
some sort of um
uh payoff for the player who is finally
going to beat gnaw so my process was my
process was when we uh I met Danielle at
the game awards and I met the cast and
crew and Matt remembered me I feel
blessed and Danielle talked me up and
they uh asked if I had done any of this
work and I showed them what I had and he
brought me in
straight to offer that's the real
actor's dream right there they just give
you a call they're like hey you're in
the game let's go
so what changed between the audition and
the performance nothing I was exactly
the same when I started and when I ended
[Laughter]
perfect
well on that note we
thank you very much
wonderful questions thank you to our
wonderful audience today and thank you
once again to the voice actors of God
thank you for your performances and for
your wonderful answers here today
and thank you to dreamhack for having us
this has been great
yes thank you everyone so much for
joining us for the God of War voice
actor panel again don't go anywhere if
you're sitting in those seats the
Creator Gauntlet is going to be
continuing right on this very stage very
shortly and those of you who are in the
dream hack twitch Channel everything
will still be streaming there as well so
don't go anywhere thank you all and
we'll see you all again soon goodbye
thank you for loving the game we love
you guys thank you
awaken for love but not your own a life
that you never thought you know
[Music]
foreign
reminds me of you
[Music]
as a loving voice
love it
[Music]